Sorry that you guys caught me off guard. I was just talking to Jason's wig maker and he had said that they don't make the hair that Jason uses for the wig anymore because it's a synthetic thing and it has to do with because they use a certain petroleum component to it, blah, blah, blah, blah. Anyway, the point is if you see Jason on the street, just please say, hey man, your natural hair looks great. It's an all new smart list. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Are you guys excited? I'm excited. Do you know what I'm talking about? Yes. I think, are you talking about our, we're on the on TV.
抱歉，你们刚才把我问懵了。我刚才在跟杰森的假发制作师聊天，他说他们不再制作杰森那种假发用的头发了，因为那是人造的，跟里面使用的一种特定石油成分有关，巴拉巴拉巴拉。总之，重点是，如果你在街上看到杰森，请对他说，嘿，老兄，你的天然头发看起来真棒。这是一个全新的 SmartLess。Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. 你们兴奋吗？我很兴奋。你们知道我在说什么吗？知道。我想，你是说我们的，我们要上电视了。
Yeah. Coming up. With the doc. We're gonna be on TV. I told my whole family. Smartless on the road. Smartless on the road. On Max.
对。即将上演。带着纪录片。我们要上电视了。我告诉我全家了。Smartless on the road。Smartless on the road。在 Max 上线。
On Max. That new platform, yes. Yeah. Yes. Should we do, should we watch it together? That's much it together. That would be super fun.
在 Max 上。那个新平台，对。对。对。我们应该，我们应该一起看吗？大家一起看。那会超级有趣。
Oh God, that's not a bad idea. I'm really excited. I'm excited for people to. See Will Ferrell. It sounds weird to say. Well, yeah, I'm excited for people to see. Well, we have so many great guests. Yes.
天哪，这主意不错。我真的很兴奋。我很高兴大家能。看到威尔·法瑞尔。说出来感觉怪怪的。好吧，是的，我很高兴大家能看到。我们有那么多优秀的嘉宾。是的。
That's a great point. Say some of the guests. We have Will Ferrell. Will starts it off though, doesn't he? Will starts it off. Then we have Conan. Yeah, and Kevin Hart. Letterman.
这话说得好。说几个嘉宾的名字。我们有威尔·法瑞尔。不过是威尔开场的，对吧？威尔开场的。然后我们有柯南。对，还有凯文·哈特。莱特曼。
Hang on, hang on. Then we have Letterman. Then we have AOC with special appearance by, can we mention that Bradley makes a special appearance. Bradley Cooper comes in, changes the light for us. And then we go to Chicago. We have Andy Richter and Jeff Tweedy from Wilco. Mark Cuban.
等等，等等。然后我们有莱特曼。然后我们有 AOC，还有特别嘉宾，我们能提一下布莱德利作为特别嘉宾出演吗？布莱德利·库珀来了，帮我们调了灯光。然后我们去芝加哥。我们有安迪·里奇特和来自 Wilco 的杰夫·特维迪。马克·库班。
Mark Cuban. And then Matty Damon. Matt Damon, the Matt. Yeah, Turtle, Quirtle, Whirtle, Perennial, Third Place, Finisher, Matt Damon. And then one of the biggest guests of the entire tour is Tracy from Wisconsin. Tracy from Wisconsin, come on, you guys.
马克·库班。然后是马蒂·达蒙。马特·达蒙，那个马特。对，小海龟，傻海龟，怪海龟，常年老三，终结者，马特·达蒙。然后是整个巡演中最大的嘉宾之一，来自威斯康星州的特蕾西。来自威斯康星州的特蕾西，拜托你们了。
Tracy, Sean's sister. My sister. Sean's sister makes an incredible appearance. Yeah, that's really good. And doesn't your mother's, your mother's right eye makes an appearance as well. Your mother's eye makes an appearance too. It's all true.
特蕾西，肖恩的妹妹。我妹妹。肖恩的妹妹作出了惊艳的客串。对，真的很棒。还有你母亲的，你母亲的右眼也客串了。你母亲的眼球也客串了。千真万确。
By the way, it's all true. And you can see it. Get it? Yeah. Don't get it. On max, smart list, on the road. Check it out. I'm glad you asked because I don't think they get it.
顺便说一句，千真万确。你能看到的。懂了吗？对。没懂。在 Max 上，Smartless on the road。去看看吧。很高兴你问了，因为我觉得他们没听懂。
And then by the way, we come back to LA and then we end here with Kimmel. With Kimmel and Kevin Hart. I mean, we get to have, what a soft land to come back and have our good buddy, Jimmy Kimmel and then Jan makes an appearance and guy, I mean. And then what's the final meal of the whole thing? Oh yeah, then we're over at Shawnee's house
然后顺便说一句，我们回到洛杉矶，最后以吉梅尔结束。有吉梅尔和凯文·哈特。我的意思是，我们能有，回到这里能有我们的好哥们吉米·吉梅尔是多么轻松的着陆，然后简客串了，天哪，我的意思是。然后整个行程的最后一餐是什么？哦，对了，然后我们去了肖妮家。
for some reason. Oh, and we go to Shawnee's, right? Was it spaghetti and meatballs? Sloppy Joe's. Sloppy Joe's. I made Sloppy Joe's for scratch for you guys. Yeah. It's all in the dock.
不知怎么的。哦，我们去了肖妮家，对吧？是意大利面配肉丸吗？滑蛋三明治。滑蛋三明治。我为你们亲手做了滑蛋三明治。对。都在纪录片里。
It's all in the dock. Are we watching it at your house? Yeah, let's watch it. Let's watch it. We'll watch it on max. It's kind of so fun. I think, I hope people like who knows, but... We hope.
都在纪录片里。我们在你家看吗？对，我们看吧。我们看吧。我们在 Max 上看。这真的很有趣。我想，我希望人们会喜欢，谁知道呢，但是……我们希望。
It looks real good too. Sam Jones did a great job directing it. It looks real handsome, it's black and white. I hope people like, it's why it's May 23rd, right? May 23rd on max. Okay. I have a crazy story that happened. I told Will, I said I was going to save it
看起来确实很棒。山姆·琼斯导演得很出色。看起来非常帅气，是黑白的。我希望人们会喜欢，这就是为什么在 5月23日，对吧？5月23日在 Max 上线。好的。我有一个发生的疯狂故事。我告诉威尔，我说我要留着。
to tell you today. You have some pre-show pattern? Yeah. You know, Shawnee. Go ahead, Shawnee. No, this is crazy. Shawnee, what have you prepared? I have prepared this.
今天告诉你。你有什么演出前的常规动作吗？对。你知道的，肖妮。说吧，肖妮。不，这太疯狂了。肖妮，你准备了什么？我准备了这个。
By the way, Dante and Rebbe is peaking and prepared. There's somebody preparing something in the kitchen behind you. Yes, Scott is going to make me some tea right now. Okay. Tea? Whoa, whoa, whoa. Are you fasting? He's on Broadway, man.
顺便说一句，丹特和瑞比正在偷听并做准备。你身后的厨房里有人在准备东西。是的，斯科特现在要给我泡杯茶。好的。茶？哇，哇，哇。你在禁食吗？他在百老汇演音乐剧，老兄。
He's on Broadway. I'm on the Broadway. Oh, to keep your pipes nice and lubricated? Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Well, it is one o'clock there. What was for lunch today? I just had a, I had a, what's it called? Like a Kaiser roll with egg and cheese and a little bacon.
他在百老汇。我在百老汇。哦，为了让你的嗓子保持润滑？嗯哼，嗯哼。好吧，那里已经一点了。今天午饭吃了什么？我刚吃了一个，我吃了，叫什么来着？就像一个凯撒面包卷，有鸡蛋和奶酪，还有一点培根。
I had, what do they call it? Like a foot long sub. A Kaiser roll. Kaiser. Yeah. Where do you have to go to get that? Like a bread shop. Downstairs.
我吃了，他们叫什么来着？就像一英尺长的潜艇堡。凯撒面包卷。凯撒。对。你在哪儿买的那个？就像面包店。楼下。
Downstairs. Downstairs. No, Zabars, Kaiser. Zabars is a Jewish deli. We live right near it. And then there's a cafe and they don't do bagels with egg. You'd think they would do bagels because they sell bagels in the store part,
楼下。楼下。不，扎巴尔斯，凯撒。扎巴尔斯是一家犹太熟食店。我们就住在它附近。然后有个咖啡馆，他们不做加蛋的贝果。你会觉得他们会做贝果，因为他们在商店部分卖贝果，
but not the cafe part, which is really crazy. You gotta go full Kaiser. All right. All right, so this is the story. This is crazy. This is going to blow your mind. I think it blew my mind. So the show takes place in 1958 backstage at the Tonight Show.
但咖啡馆部分不卖，这真的很疯狂。你得去买正宗的凯撒。好了。好了，这就是这个故事。太疯狂了。这会震惊到你的。我想它也震惊了我。所以这个故事发生在 1958 年《今夜秀》的后台。
Oskar Levant is the guest on the Tonight Show that night. The other guest, which we never see, we only reference a lot is Jane Mansfield. Sure. Okay. Who was, you know, this big star back in the 50s. Marilyn Monroe, Jane Mansfield, very similar. So Mariska Hargitay, you know Mariska Hargitay?
奥斯卡·莱万特是那天晚上《今夜秀》的嘉宾。另一个嘉宾，我们从来没见她出现，只是经常被提及，那就是简·曼斯菲尔德。没错。好吧。她你知道的，是 50 年代的大明星。玛丽莲·梦露、简·曼斯菲尔德，非常相似。所以玛莉丝卡·哈吉塔伊，你知道玛莉丝卡·哈吉塔伊吗？
I do. Yeah, she's the star of the SVU thing. Oh, thanks, Scotty. And thanks, Scotty. Thanks, Scotty. He just made me tea. So she's the star of this show for like 20 some years, right? So she's like, I'm outside of your theater.
我知道。对，她是《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》的主演。哦，谢谢，斯科蒂。还有谢谢，斯科蒂。谢谢，斯科蒂。他刚给我泡了茶。所以她在这个节目里演了大概二十多年，对吧？所以她说，我在你剧院外面。
Come out. And I'm like, oh my God, I came out, gave her a hug, said hello, we took a photo, we're done. And somebody in the show whispers in my ear, her mom is Jane Mansfield. I go, wait a minute, what? Yeah. Well, Mariska Hargitay's mom,
出来吧。我说，哦天哪，我出去了，给了她一个拥抱，打了个招呼，我们拍了张照，就结束了。然后剧组里有人在我耳边低语，她妈妈是简·曼斯菲尔德。我说，等等，什么？是的。好吧，玛莉丝卡·哈吉塔伊的妈妈，
I go, your mom is Jane Mansfield. I go, do you know that we reference your mom in this show over and over again? Did your mom know Oskar Levant? And she's like, I don't, I don't know. You know, unfortunately she was very young when her mom died. So then we go back and we say her buys. I go back in the theater and I forgot, I texted her.
我说，你妈妈是简·曼斯菲尔德。我说，你知道我们在节目里一遍又一遍地提到你妈妈吗？你妈妈认识奥斯卡·莱万特吗？她说，我不知道，我不知道。你知道，不幸的是，她妈妈去世时她还很小。然后我们回去，说再见。我回到剧院，然后我忘了，我给她发了条短信。
I go, by the way, your mom made her Broadway debut in this theater that we're working in right now. Wow. Isn't that crazy? Crazy, crazy, yeah. And so, did you at least offer her tickets to the show? No, she's gotta pay for those. Yeah, yeah.
我说，顺便说一句，你妈妈是在我们现在工作的这家剧院完成她的百老汇处女秀的。哇。是不是很疯狂？疯狂，疯狂，是的。所以，你至少送了她演出门票吗？不，她得自己买票。对，对。
I mean, you can give her access to the house. Yeah, I can get her. Her dad, her dad was Mickey Hargitay, who was like a bodybuilder guy from Hungary. How do you know that? I know that. She just Googled it. No, I didn't.
我是说，你可以给她后台通行证。对，我可以给她。她爸爸，她爸爸是米奇·哈吉塔伊，是个来自匈牙利的健美运动员。你怎么知道的？我知道。她刚刚谷歌搜索的。没有，我没有。
I knew that before and... Wait, why do you know vague Hungarian bodybuilders? Look, do you want to see my magazine collection or not? No, I don't want to see your search history. I do, I actually do. I read somebody in my search history the other day. It was such a bonkers all over the map. I go, here, do you want to know what I've been searching up
我以前就知道，而且……等等，你为什么知道冷门匈牙利健美运动员？听着，你想看我的杂志收藏还是不想？不，我不想看你的搜索历史。我想看，我其实想看。我前几天在我的搜索历史里读到了一些东西。简直是乱七八糟、莫名其妙。我说，给你，你想知道我过去 24 小时都在搜索什么吗？
for the last 24 hours? And it was just the weirdest, stupidest stuff. I want to say just because I want to be, and I don't want to bring it down, but I got to be honest about where I'm at, if that's okay. Yes, yes. Today, and then we can switch gears. Is that okay?
全都是最奇怪、最蠢的东西。我想说，只是因为我想，我不想把气氛搞砸，但我得对我的现状坦诚，如果这可以的话。可以，可以。今天，然后我们可以转换话题。这样可以吗？
Of course it is. It's very real. Do you want me to say? Do you want me to describe it? My oldest friend in the world, Jeremy, passed away. And I loved him so much. Oh, well, I'm so sorry. Yeah, you just found out yesterday, yeah?
当然可以。这很真实。你想让我说吗？你想让我描述一下吗？我世上最好的朋友杰瑞，去世了。我太爱他了。哦，天哪，我很遗憾。是的，你昨天刚得知消息，对吧？
Yeah. And I just got to be honest about it because it's what's going on in my head. And I just wanted to say that I just, I love the guy so much. And it's so, Jason and I were talking today this morning and it's funny, we always get surprised when people then you say,
对。我必须对此坦诚，因为这就是我脑子里想的。我只想说我，我太爱这家伙了。太……杰森和我今天早上还在谈论，有趣的是，当人们说出这句话时，我们总是感到惊讶，
it's such a surprise, such a shock. And we know that the deal is that everybody's going to die in something. Yeah, we're here for five minutes. Yeah. And you passed suddenly, well. You know, the last few weeks were kind of came out and nowhere, certainly, and then he finally passed.
这太令人惊讶了，太震惊了。我们知道事实是每个人终究都会死。对，我们在这里只待五分钟。对。而且你走得突然，唉。你知道，过去几周情况有点毫无征兆地恶化，然后他终于去世了。
And I'm happy he did, he was, you know, obviously he was in a lot of pain. And I'm just thinking about his family and all of them, and I've known them forever and his daughter and his wife and his parents, who my parents knew and our great-grandparents knew each other. Our families are intertwined for generations.
我很高兴他解脱了，他，你知道，显然他承受了很大的痛苦。我只是在想他的家人和他们所有人，我和他们认识很久了，还有他的女儿、妻子和父母，我的父母认识他们，我们的曾祖父母就认识。我们的家族几代人交织在一起。
And he was- So Jeremy was up in Toronto? He was in Toronto, yeah. And he was one of the great guys. He's a, I always say he's a first ballot hall of famer, just a great guy. You could always rely on him and I miss him. And, you know, you never,
他是——所以杰瑞在多伦多？他在多伦多，是的。他是个了不起的人。他是一个，我总是说他是首轮入选名人堂的人，真是个大好人。你总是可以依赖他，我很想念他。而且，你知道，你永远不会，
and I was just thinking this morning, you know, I was taking the kids to school and it was just thinking like, oh man, hug the people you love. Yeah. Tell them as much as you can. And if you're thinking about somebody, call them. Let them know.
我今天早上还在想，你知道，我送孩子们上学时就在想，哦天哪，去拥抱你爱的人吧。对。尽可能多地告诉他们。如果你在想某个人，就给她打电话。让她知道。
Right. Just let them know you're thinking about them. And you love them how important they are to you. I love that. And I just wanted to say that because it's all my mind and I love you guys so much. We love you. We love you too.
对。就让她知道你在想她。你有多爱他们，他们对你有多重要。我喜欢这样。我只想说这些，因为这充斥着我的脑海，我太爱你们了。我们爱你。我们也爱你。
Yeah. Yeah, it's, it is, you're right. It is this sort of like, we're always shocked that people died but everyone here is going to. Everyone listening will. And it's like, it's a terrible thought and we somehow have managed this little device
对。是的，这，确实是，你说得对。这就好像，我们总是对人们的离去感到震惊，但这里的每个人都会死。听广播的每个人都会。这真是一个可怕的想法，我们不知怎么地在我们的大脑和心里设计了这样一个小装置，把它放进一个小盒子，藏起来，直到生命的尽头才去面对。我们只是假装它永远不会发生，但它确实会发生，我们只希望我们能正确地利用时间。
inside our head and our heart to kind of put it in a little box and keep it away and deal with it near the end of our life. We just kind of pretend it's not ever going to happen but it does and we just hope we use our time correctly. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, for sure. You know, I, I just did this,
对。对，对，确实如此。你知道，我，我刚刚做过这个，我刚刚做了这篇文章，这次采访，杰伊，你太好了。我刚读过。你对我的评价那么好，我很感激。我很感激你的慷慨。而且，而且我说，我说，你知道，如果我能演好这部戏，那就太好了。如果不能，我还活着。
I just did this article, this interview and Jay, you were so kind. I just read it. You said such nice things about me and I appreciate it. I appreciate your generosity. And, and I said, I said, you know, if I can pull this thing off, great. If not, I'm still alive.
对。这是我的名言，你知道的。哦，关于这部剧。所以你对这部剧很看好。对，我可能演得很烂，但至少我没死。不，但重点是，说到你的观点，威尔，这就像我们依然在，我们在这里。我们在这里，对吧？
Yeah. It's my quote, you know. Oh, about the play. So you're feeling bullish about the play. Yeah, you could suck, but at least I'm not dead. No, but the point is to your point, well, it's like we're still, we're here. We're here, right?
我们在这里。我们在这里。除了我们的健康、我们爱的人以及所有这些之外，其他什么都不重要。还有我们爱的人，然后，是的，我想说这些，只想说，杰瑞，我们爱你。就这样。
We're here. We're here. Nothing matters other than our health and our people we love and all of that. And the people we love and, and I just, yeah, I wanted to say that, just say, Jared, we love you. And, and that's it.
你知道的，老兄，我在想你。而且，我也知道他，他也很容易笑，他非常喜欢放声大笑。这家伙让我发笑。所以，我不知道，他会觉得，太好了，威尔，快去找你的嘉宾吧。对。
You know, I'm thinking about you, buddy. And, and I also know that he was, he was also quick with a laugh and he loved to freaking laugh. This guy made me laugh. And so, I don't know, he would, he'd be like, great, well, get to your guest. Yeah.
所以。是的。这个周末，你将有机会与你刚才提到的那些人一起，好好地向他做个告别。没错。对他来说，能看到这一幕是一件美好的事情。没错。你知道，我是说，那是……的好处之一
So. Yeah. You have a nice opportunity to give him a nice goodbye this weekend with all of those people you're talking about. That's right. That's a wonderful thing for, for him to watch. That's right. You know, I mean, the, that's one of the good things
在我们离去之后，对吧？我们去干嘛，就像，这是一场自恋狂的狂欢。你可以搬把椅子坐下，看着每个人说你的好话。对，对，对，对。我，我喜欢这样。至少这是我的幻想。我知道。
about after we go, right? We get to what, like, it's a narcissist delight. You get to just pull up a chair and watch everybody say nice things about you. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I, I love that. At least that's my fantasy. I know.
好吧，这是你的幻想之一。没错。整整一天的大型杰森专场。你在吃什么？现在？不，在那种你去了之后不再重要的情况下。只是一些超级咸的、让人发胖的东西。
Well, it's one of your fantasies. Right. Just a big Jason session for a whole day. What are you eating? Right now? No, in that situation where you go, where it doesn't matter anymore. It's just a super salty puff inducing things.
因为，你知道，你在上面想多胖就可以多胖。当然，你可以。对。你可以来。事实证明你在下面也可以想多胖就多胖。好吧，其实你在下面几乎瞬间就能减掉水分，因为你一直在出汗。对。
Cause, you know, you can be as puffy as you want upstairs. Sure, you can. Yeah. You can come. Turns out you can be as puffy as you want downstairs too. Well, actually you lose water weight almost instantaneously down there because you're always sweating. Yeah.
对。热得要命。哦，你要去的地方。对，你要出很多汗。说得好。这是一场持续不断的适应。转换话题。当然。
Yeah. It's hot as shit. Oh, where you're going. Yeah, you're going to get a lot of sweating going on. That's a good point. It's a constant fit. To switch gears. Sure.
你知道的，如果可以的话，我们要谈一个一点也不胖的人。真的吗？没有，这位先生保持得非常紧致，以最好的方式。我真的。幸运的混蛋。对，我知道他真的是。
You know, if we can, as much as we can to somebody who's not puffy. Really? No. This gentleman keeps it very tight in the best way. I really. Lucky son of a bitch. Yeah, I know he really is.
他有，这是一个家伙。你想谈论首轮入选名人堂的人。这就是那个拥有一切的人。我的意思是，这些，当你拥有，当你拥有，当你拥有才华和美貌时，别提了。当你有一种随和的作风时。哦，天哪。棒极了。
He's got, this is a guy. You want to talk about First Ballad Hall of Famer. This is the guy who's got it all. I mean, these, when you got, when you got, when you got talent and good looks, forget about it. When you got an easy way about you. Oh boy. For a freaking good.
这家伙什么都干过。他上过大银幕。他上过小屏幕。他上过板子，你知道的，在舞台上，如果你愿意的话。这家伙来自大西洋的另一边。哦哦。他是英国人。是的。
This guy's done it everything. He's been on the big screen. He's been on the little screen. He's been on the boards, you know, on stage, if you will. This guy's from the other side of the pond. Uh-oh. He's British. Yeah.
好吧，他其实是威尔士人。根据互联网的说法，他的母语是威尔士语。他是一个做过很多事情的家伙。而且他，他是那种让你每次见到他都会觉得，哦，我太喜欢这家伙了。他做的每一件事。这就是我的感受。你知道，多年来，
Well, he's actually Welsh. His first language is Welsh according to the internet. He's a guy who's done so much. And he's, he's one of those guys who'd like you just, every time you see him, you're like, oh, I love this guy. Everything he does. This is the way I feel. You know, he was for years,
他在，你从《兄弟姐妹》中认识他。然后他在《美国谍梦》里待了很久。我最喜欢他的地方，或许是他是和我最喜欢的人之一搭档，也就是可爱的凯丽·罗素，伙计们。这就是才华横溢的马修·瑞斯。哦，马修。
he was on, you knew him from brothers and sisters. And then he was on the Americans forever. And the thing I love about him, maybe the most is that he is partnered with one of my all-time favorite people, the delightful Kerry Russell guys. It's the incredibly talented Matthew Reese. Oh, Matthew.
哦，天哪。是的。看他。看他。看这气势。看这气势。看这气势。看他。
Oh my God. Yes. Look at him. Look at him. Look at this dash. Look at this dash. Look at this dash. Look at him.
那张脸上一点水分也没有。不，多年来都没有。我们今天有第五位嘉宾。他刚刚，他证明了胡子是真的。他扯了一下以证明这一点。不，不，我只是检查，我检查一下胶水。听众朋友们，他粘了三十磅重的胡子，看起来很带劲。
No water in that face at all. No, not for years. We have a fifth guest today. He just, he proved that the mustache was real. He pulled on it just to prove it. No, no, I'm just checking, I'm checking the glue. Listener, he's got a 30 pound mustache on and it's looking strong.
你在扮演摩托车交警吗？不，我在拍汤姆·塞立克的传记片。你可以，你可以，欢迎 Smartless 嘉宾马修·瑞斯。马修，你站着，很高兴见到你。谢谢，谢谢，非常感谢。你知道，那才是，那是真正可怕的时刻，揭晓的时候。我知道。
Are you playing a motorcycle cop? No, I'm doing the Tom Selleck biopic. You could, you could welcome to smartless Matthew Reese. Matthew, you stood, good to see you. Thank you, thank you very much. You know, that's the, that's the real terrifying moment, the reveal. I know.
因为一开始我在想，他在说伊恩·麦克莱恩吗？他们期待谁？这是要干嘛？这是要演。是塔伦·埃哲顿，各位。真正的威尔士人，谁说得准呢？当然。
Because at the beginning I was like, is he talking about Ian McKellen? Who are they expecting? What is this? This is going to go. It's Taryn Edgerton, everyone. The real Welshman, who can say? Sure.
哇，很高兴认识你。我知道。非常，非常酷。谢谢，非常感谢邀请我来，先生们，这真是我的荣幸。马修，我希望我们还不够熟。我们有过几次交集，因为显然我和凯丽是老朋友。
Wow, it's so cool to meet you. I know. Very, very cool. And thank you, thank you very much for having me on, Gents, this is a real pleasure. Matthew, I wish we don't know each other well enough. We've crossed paths a few times because obviously Carrie and I are old friends.
所以我们通过凯丽认识了。正如你所知，她是一个如此可爱的人。然后她说，我只是，我喜欢这个想法。我说，你跟什么样的人交往，你就是什么样的人。你和凯丽在一起，我就觉得，马修是个好人。他是个伟大的人。我只需——
And so we've met through Carrie. And she's such a delightful person as you were well aware. And then she's like, I just, I love the idea. I'm like, you're as good as the people you hang out with. And the fact that you and Carrie together, I'm like, Matthew's a good guy. He's a great guy. I can just-
不，我只是，不，我接受了，我接受了这个想法。然后我把自己缠了上去。这样我们周围的人也会这么想。顺便说一句，这很聪明，这才是聪明的生存之道。你们一起拍那个剧多久了？五年，六年？六年，六年。本来是打算拍五年的。
No, I just, no, I took, I took that idea. And then I latched myself on together. So that those around us would think the same thing. By the way, that's smart, that's smart livin'. How long did you guys do that show together? Was it five, six? It was six, it was six years. It was meant to be five.
我想可怜的运作人已经为五年做好了剧情大纲。然后 FX 说，你知道吗，再拍一季吧。他们说，什么，什么，什么？我们不问。这挺好。我们遇到了相反的情况。这对一部剧来说是个好兆头。我们当然是在谈论《美国谍梦》。
And I think the poor showrunners had kind of arced it for five. And then FX went, you know what, let's do one more. And they went, what, what, what? We don't ask. That's nice. We had the opposite. That's a good sign on a show. We're talking, of course, about the Americans.
是的。玛戈·马丁代尔是个朋友。亲爱的，亲爱的玛戈·马丁代尔。是的。他们最近都在《可卡因熊》里重聚了。是的。所以玛戈，你也在《可卡因熊》里。我糊里糊涂地混进去了。
Yeah. And Margot Martindale's a friend. And dear, dear Margot Martindale. Yeah. They were both reunited on Cocaine Bear recently. Yes. So Margot, and you did, you were in Cocaine Bear as well. I muffled my way in.
在爱尔兰照顾孩子时读了剧本，看了那个开场镜头，我说，我当时就想，那家伙是谁？那个撞了头从飞机掉下去的家伙。她问，谁？我不知道。然后我说，我问了，我问了伊丽莎白·班克斯。我说，我问班克斯，谁演那个角色？
Just looking after the kids in Ireland and reading the script and that first opening scene, I said, I was like, who's playing that guy? The guy who bangs his head and falls out the plane. She's like, who? I don't know. And then I said, I asked, I asked Elizabeth Banks. I said, I asked Banks, who's playing that part?
所以她给班克斯发了短信，哦，我们还没选好角呢。我说，告诉她我来演。我说，不，不，只问她我能不能演。她非常友善地说，可以，你可以来从飞机上掉下来。顺便说一句，这绝对是一种享受。所以你在导演一部电影，然后你有一个只有一场戏的家伙，基本上。
So she texted Banks, oh, we haven't cast it yet. And I said, tell her I'll do it. I said, no, no, just ask her if I can do it. And she very kindly said, yes, you can come in and fall out of an airplane. By the way, what an absolute treat. So you're directing a movie and then you got a guy who's got like one scene, basically.
然后你说，马修·瑞斯打来电话。他说，嘿，我能只演这一场戏吗？你当时想，你在开玩笑吗？是的，她闻到了我身上的绝望。我当时想，求求你让我离开家吧。我不能再去另一个动物园或水族馆了，求求了。肖恩，那个传言是真的吗？抱歉，那是你和斯科特相遇的方式，对吧？
And then you're like, Matthew Rees calls in. He's like, hey, can I just do this one scene? You're like, are you kidding? Yeah, she smelled the desperation on me. I was like, can I please get out of the house? I can't do another zoo or aquarium, please. Sean, is it true the rumor? Sorry, that's how you and Scott met, right?
你不是在搜索可卡因熊吗？没有，我没听说过吗？不，技术上讲，那是可卡因幼熊，对吧？那是可卡因幼熊。对，那是他们还没拍的前传。哦，斯科蒂。哦，斯科蒂，如果他知道的话。所以你演了可卡因，当然我不想一带而过
Didn't you put in the search for cocaine bear? And no, did I not hear that? No, I think technically it was cocaine cub, wasn't it? It was cocaine cub. Yeah, it was the prequel that they haven't done. Oh, Scotty. Oh, Scotty, if he only knew. So you do cocaine, and of course I don't want to just gloss
我们都喜爱的可爱的玛戈·马丁代尔。哦，是的，她是最好的。没人能像玛戈·马丁代尔那样说脏话。我的意思，她应该在纽约大学开设一门课程，比如电影和电视中的脏话，因为没人能像她那样骂人。而且没有人能比她更快地被激怒，然后因为一些看似琐碎的事情开始骂人
over the delightful Margo Martindale, whom we all adore. Oh yeah, she's the greatest. No one can swear like Margo Martindale. I mean, she should have a kind of course at NYU, like swearing for film and television, because no one can swear like her. And no one can get their ire up quicker and then get to swearing over like something
我们一起拍过那部剧，《米勒一家》，她会说，你敢相信他们刚刚读了剧本，而我他妈的得记住这他妈的东西，他们还想今天下午就拍。她会说，天哪，什么？是的。她说，如果剧组里有个非常著名的演员，
that seems trivial. We did the show together, the Millers, and she'd be like, can you believe they just did this read and I got to fucking remember this fucking thing and they want to shoot this afternoon. She's like, Jesus, what? Yeah. She said, if one very famous actor who's in our show,
她说，你他妈能听到他的呼吸声吗？我说，好吧，我会表演出来，其实我没有，但我现在能听到了。你提出来的。我会和她合作的。所以，杰森，你不想和玛戈·马丁代尔合作。杰森，你会深深爱上玛戈·马丁代尔的。你无法控制自己。
she went, can you fucking hear the way he breathes? I went, well, I'd perform it, and I had no, I haven't actually, but I can hear it now. You brought it up. I'll work with her. So, Jason, you don't want to work with Margo Martindale. Jason, you will so fall in love with Margo Martindale. You won't be able to contain yourself.
伙计们，我说的对吗？是的，她是最好的。绝对是无价之宝。现在告诉我，威尔士语是一门语言。我听到你这么说了吗，威尔？哦，天哪。首先……等等，所以这不是英语？
Guys, am I right? Yeah, she's the greatest. She's absolutely gold. Now, tell me, Welsh is a language. Is that what I heard you say, Will? Oh, my God. First of all... Wait, so it's not English?
对，准备好字母表。这不是英语。它比英语古老得多。是的。它是欧洲最古老的语言之一。所以我们从这开始。我只是想说，马修，你……上面说你的母语是威尔士语。
Yeah, ready for the letters. It's not English. It's much older than English. Yeah. It's one of the oldest in Europe. So let's start there. So I just want to say, so Matthew, you are... It says that your first language was Welsh.
是真的吗？是的。是的。我是在说威尔士语的环境中长大的。全家都说威尔士语。但威尔士语不就是带口音的英语吗？我不明白。是的，基本上。
Is that true? It is. It is. I grew up speaking Welsh. The whole family speak Welsh. But isn't Welsh just English with an accent? I don't understand. Yes, basically.
我们只是……我们所做的是尝试采用一种如此刺耳的口音。没有人真正听得懂说的是什么英语。不，不，不，不。那是……他在逗你玩。是的。我在加的夫待过一段时间，你就是那里的人，对吧，马修？
We just... What we do is try and adopt such a harsh accent. No one really understands the English of speaking. No, no, no, no, no. That's... He's putting you on. Yeah. I've spent some time in Cardiff, which is where you're from, yeah, Matthew?
是的。你在那里干什么？几年前我在那里拍戏，我记得我们有这个……你当时开什么车？我有……我本想说，我拍那部剧时遇到的司机，你知道那个家伙——杰瑞·洛克特？是的，杰瑞·洛克特。
It is. What were you doing there? I was filming there a few years ago, and I remember we had this... What were you driving? I had... I was going to say, the driver I had when I was working on that show, you know the guy... Jerry Lockett? Yes, Jerry Lockett.
哦，洛克特火箭。是的。著名的杰瑞·洛克特。是的。你什么意思，司机？你在说什么？你有一辆劳斯莱斯。我就是想拿这个话引诱你。
Oh, the Lockett Rocket. Yeah. The famous Jerry Lockett. Yes. What do you mean, driver? What are you talking about? You had a Rolls Royce. That's what I was trying to bait you to.
难道没有人借给你……哦，不，不，不。借给你……我在伦敦时，开着它兜风了几周。你太恶心了。我知道。说来话长。右舵。
Didn't somebody loan you... Oh, no, no, no. Loan you... When I was in Bentley, when I was in London, I was drove around for a few weeks. You're disgusting. I know. It's a long story. Right side drive.
等等，你开着这辆宾利自己开车？对，我自己开。右舵？当然是。哦，天哪。然后我开车去了伦敦里奇的杰维斯的家，因为我要去……去他家拜访一下。
Wait, did you drive yourself in this Bentley? Yeah, I did. I drove myself. Right side drive? Sure did. Oh, my God. And then I drove up to Ricky's to Jervis' house in London, because I was going to have... Go to his house to have just a visit.
你是谁？谁是我的……我给他打电话说，我在外面，他出来了，看到我开着这辆宾利，我说，这东西能停在哪儿？他当时说，耶稣基督他妈的。听着，它不是我的。它简直是……我才不开了辆宾利。
Who are you? Who's my... And I called him and I said, I'm outside, and he came out, and he saw me in this Bentley and I go, where can I park this thing around here? And he was like, Jesus fucking Christ. Look, it wasn't mine. It was literally... I don't drive a Bentley.
这就是我刚才特意要说的话。不管怎样，你是从加的夫来的。我们认识杰瑞·洛克特。我们的老朋友杰瑞在那儿。我们知道他在听。我们爱你，杰瑞。所以我们知道你是谁。火箭洛克特。
That was why I made a point. Anyway, so you're from Cardiff. We know Jerry Lockett. We've got Jerry out there. We know that he's listening. We love you, Jerry. So we know who you do. Rocket Lockett.
你好吗？我知道你们俩认识，因为他总是说，你认识马修·瑞斯吗？我说，我认识。我稍微认识一点，因为我认识凯丽。他说，是的，马修就是这儿的人，他为你感到骄傲，所有威尔士人都为马修你所取得的成就感到骄傲。我觉得……
How are you? And I knew that you guys knew each other, because he was always like, do you know Matthew Reese? And I was like, I do. I do a little bit, because I know Kerry. And he says, yeah, Matthew's from here, and he's so proud of you and all the Welsh are so proud of Matthew for what you've done. I think there's...
因为我们只有三百万人口，三百五十万。那是整个加拿大，对吧？什么？首先……现在加拿大的总人口是多少？3000万，3000万。哦，好吧。你少算了一个零。
Because there's only three million of us, three and a half million. That's all of Canada, isn't it? What? First of all... What is the population of Canada now? 30, 30. Oh, okay. You missed it by a zero.
百分之十。所以任何威尔士人，只要做过任何事，甚至什么都没做，我们对一个康涅狄格州大小的国家都有一种天然的骄傲，我在说这个。他们中有人叫贝尔，还有人叫瑞斯？是的，就是这样。基本上就这样。克里斯蒂安、加雷斯、贝尔和马修·瑞斯。
Ten percent. Yeah. So anyone who's Welsh and has done anything, even if they haven't done anything, we're just inherently proud for a country the size of Connecticut, which I'm talking about. Who are them are named Bale, and one of them is named Reese? Yes, that's it. That's basically it. So Christian, Gareth, and Bale, and Matthew Reese.
嗯，还有霍普金斯。你还有霍普金斯。哦，是的，确实有。还有伯顿，显然。有很多。所以等等，我对你一无所知，我知道你，我是你的粉丝，但我对任何人都不了解。
Well, there's also Hopkins. You also got Hopkins. Oh, yeah, you do. Yeah. And in Burton, obviously. There are a bunch. So wait, I don't know anything about you, and I know you, I'm a fan of you, but I don't know anybody.
你……所以你是那种从小在剧院长大的人，当时想，哦天哪，如果我能去美国，哇。我们要聊到那个，肖恩。完全正确。他正说到故事的兴头上。他在讲故事。劳斯莱斯和宾利的故事是怎么回事？
Did you... So were you one of those people that grew up in the theater and stuff as a kid, and you're like, oh my God, if I can go to America, wow. We're going to get to that, Sean. That's exactly right. He's right in the middle of a story. He's telling a story. What's the story about a Rolls Royce and a Bentley?
说威尔士语是他的母语。说点威尔士语。他快把这话题聊完了。好吧，抱歉。请继续，马修。威尔士语是怎么回事？肖恩，请查看你的聊天记录。所以谈到，不，在说威尔士语的环境中长大，你们在家说威尔士语，对吧？
Speaking Welsh is his first language. Say something Welsh. He's landing the plane on that. Okay, sorry. Go ahead, Matthew. What's the Welsh? Sean, check your chat, please. So talk about, no, but growing up speaking Welsh, you guys spoke Welsh at home, yeah?
是的。是的。在威尔士，人们对表演艺术有着极大的敬意，有一种古老的传统，可以追溯到基督教之前，每当老人们聚集在一起时，大家就会进行歌唱比赛、朗诵诗歌或类似的一切，基本上，现在这非常现代，但一年两次，威尔士所有的孩子们会聚在一起，现在这是一场比赛，但非常鼓励你以这样或那样的艺术形式登上舞台，为你的学校或县
We did. We did. And in Wales, there's a great reverence for performing arts, and there's a kind of an ancient tradition, dates, it's pre-Christian, whereby everyone congregates, when the old people congregate, and then you would sing competitively, or cite poetry, or anything of that ilk, basically, and it's very modern these days, but twice a year, all the children of Wales will gather, and it's a competition now, but you're very much encouraged to get on stage in some form, art form or another, and compete for your school or your county
或其他什么去竞争。哦，哇。所以，是的，从很小的时候起，你不管是自愿还是被迫，都会被推上舞台。真的吗？现在，插播一则赞助商广告。SmartLess 得到了 Think 的支持。如果你和我一样，你可能经常考虑做很多事情，比如获得更多
or whatever. Oh, wow. So, yeah, so from a very early age, you're kind of kicked onto a stage, whether you want to. Really? And now, a word from our sponsor. SmartLess is supported by Think. If you're anything like me, you probably think about doing a lot of things, getting more
锻炼，花更多时间在户外，或者吃得更好，我必须这么做，但你难道不想把这些付诸行动吗？这正是我们在 Think 的朋友们今年春天挑战我们所有人要做的事情，不仅要“思维强大”，还要“行动强大”，因为你比你想象的还要强大。当你去远足一条新小径、完成锻炼，或者只是更加关注你的饮食时，你可以享用美味、高蛋白的 Think 棒来补充能量，它含有高达 20 克的蛋白质，只有 0 到 5 克的克糖，还有一系列非常美味的口味。你会觉得自己有能力完成这一切。
exercise, spending more time outdoors or eating better, which I have to do, but wouldn't you like to turn that into action? That's exactly what our friends at Think are challenging us all to do this spring, to not only think strong, but act strong, because you're stronger than you think. And while you're out hiking a new trail, finishing your workout, or just being more mindful of what you eat, you can snack strong with great-tasting, high-protein think bars, with up to 20 grams of protein, only zero to five grams of sugar, and a range of seriously delicious flavors. You'll feel strong enough to do it all.
很多时候，当我在百老汇演这出戏时，我会步行去剧院，这很棒，这是很好的锻炼，但我会随身带一根 Think 棒在路上吃，这样我演戏时就有精力了。这是边走边吃的好时机。你同时在做两件伟大的事情，用健康的能量棒将好东西摄入体内，同时步行和锻炼。所以今年春天出门吧，带上 Think 蛋白棒一起上路，在你最喜欢的商店和 ThinkProducts.com 均有售。
A lot of the times, as I'm doing this play on Broadway, I'll walk to the theater, which is great, it's great exercise, but I grab a think bar with me to eat on the way so that I have energy to do the show. It's the perfect time to just kind of like walk and eat. You're doing two great things at one time, putting great stuff into your body with a healthy bar and walking and exercising. So get out there this spring and take Think protein bars along for the ride, available at your favorite stores and ThinkProducts.com.
就是 ThinkProducts.com，连在一起的。SmartLess 得到了 BetterHelp 的赞助。对我来说，我知道我总是谈论自私。当你花那么多时间照顾自己时，感觉就像是自私，但如果不照顾好自己，你就无法为别人付出。嗯，有时我发现自己太照顾自己了。看？这双向都行。
It's ThinkProductsOneWord.com. SmartLiz is sponsored by BetterHelp. So for me, I know I always talk about being selfish. It feels like being selfish when you take so much time for yourself, but you can't be there for other people if you don't take care of yourself. Well, sometimes I find myself taking too much care of myself. See? It can work both ways.
我没有花足够的时间在斯科蒂需要的事情上，或者朋友和家人需要的事情上。所以你必须弄清楚这种不断的平衡。这就像，等等，我为自己做太多了。等等，我为自己做的不够。所以这是你脑海中不断进行的斗争，关于如何在为他人付出的同时平衡我的生活，以及为自己付出，反之亦然。有时候，很容易陷入满足其他人对你的需求的漩涡中，却从不花时间去思考你对自己的需求是什么，反之亦然。
I'm not spending enough time with what Scotty needs or friends or family need. So there is that constant balance you got to figure out. It's like, wait, I'm doing too much for myself. Wait, I'm not doing too much for myself. So it's a constant battle in your brain about how do I balance my life with being there for other people while being there for myself and vice versa. It's so easy to get caught up in what everyone else needs from you sometimes and never take a moment to think about what you need from yourself and vice versa.
但当我们把所有时间都用来奉献时，有时会让我们感到筋疲力尽、精疲力竭。无论如何，心理治疗总是能帮我找到这种平衡。我知道我经常谈论它，但它确实管用。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线，旨在方便、灵活并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证心理治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。
But when we spend all of our time giving sometimes it can leave us feeling stretched thin and burnt out. Anyway, therapies always help me try to find that balance. I know I speak about it a lot, but it really does work. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
通过 BetterHelp 寻找更多平衡。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 smartlist，首月可享 10% 的折扣。即 BetterHelpHELP.com 斜杠 smartlist。感谢支持 SmartLess 的 Game Time。所以我在百老汇演出。我晚上没有太多时间，因为我所有的晚上都被占满了，但当我确实有那个难得的晚上可以去看点什么或做点什么时，你知道，我总是担心，我们该怎么做？
Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartlist. Thanks to Game Time, supporting smartlist. So I'm doing the show on Broadway. I don't have a lot of time at night because all my nights are taken up, but when I do have that rare time at night when I can go see something or do something, you know, I'm always stressed out about like, how do we do it?
我们去哪儿？我们怎么买票？这太紧张了，因为购买你最喜欢的活动的门票不应该是紧张的。Game Time 是购买你附近的体育、音乐、喜剧和戏剧门票的快速简便的方法，这正是我们所做的。凭借最后一分钟门票的超级优惠和最低价格保证，你可以停止为门票感到压力，开始为即将到来的乐趣感到兴奋。这正是我和斯科蒂所做的。
Where do we go? How do we get tickets? It's so stressful because buying tickets to your favorite events shouldn't be stressful. Game Time is the fast and easy way to buy tickets for all the sports, music, comedy and theater near you, which is exactly what we did. With killer deals on last minute tickets and their best price guarantee, you can stop stressing over the tickets and start getting hyped for the fun you'll have. So that's exactly what Scotty and I did.
我们打开 Game Time 应用，在难得的休息日买到了我们都非常想看的演出的门票，棒极了。尽管提前几个月做计划，Game Time 仍然提供直到活动当天都有的门票优惠。Game Time 保证意味着你总能获得最优惠的价格。如果你在同一区域和排找到更便宜的门票，Game Time 将退还你 110% 的差价。太棒了。
We went to Game Time app and we got tickets to a show that we both really wanted to see on one of my very few nights off and it was fantastic. Despite planning months in advance, Game Time has deals on tickets right up to the day of the event. The Game Time guarantee means you'll always get the best price. If you find tickets in the same section in row for less, Game Time will credit you 110% of the difference. That's amazing.
通过 Game Time 轻松抢票，绝无压力。下载 Game Time 应用，创建一个账户，并使用代码 SMARTLESS，首次购买即可立减 20 美元。条款适用。再次强调，创建一个账户并兑换代码 SMARTLESS 立减 20 美元。今天的 Game Time，最后一分钟门票，最低价格保证。好了，回到节目中。所以你长大了，你在说，很显然你也说英语。
Snag the tickets without the stress with Game Time. Download the Game Time app, create an account and use code SMARTLESS for $20 off your first purchase. Terms apply. Again, create an account and redeem code SMARTLESS for $20 off. Game Time today, last minute tickets, lowest price guaranteed. All right, back to the show. So you grew up, you're speaking, well, obviously you speak English as well.
他们在那里两种语言都说。威尔士的标牌等等太有趣了。一个是英文的，一个是威尔士语的，很难读。这是一个充满争议的温床。英语和威尔士语之间的差距有多大？我的意思是，我完全不知道它听起来像什么，看起来像什么。是的，我会说一点威尔士语，这样我们就能听到它了。威尔士最古老的诗歌之一大约作于公元前 600 年，它只是说，
They speak both there. The signage and stuff in Wales is delightful. It's one in English and one in Welsh and it's tough to read. It's a hot bed of contention. What's the distance between English and Welsh? I mean, I have absolutely no idea what it sounds like, what it looks like. Yeah, I'll talk a little bit in Welsh just so we can hear it. One of the oldest poems in Welsh is about 600 BC and it just says,
这是《指环王》，精灵。这就是《指环王》中精灵说话的方式。是的，我们在讨论基于威尔士语的精灵语。哦，我刚编的。真的吗？哦，确实是。你在开玩笑吗？我的意思是，我是一个 54 岁不住在山洞里的男人。
It's Lord of the Rings, the elves. It's how the elves speak in Lord of the Rings. Yes, we're talking based elfish on Welsh. Oh, I just made that up. Is that true? Oh, yes it is. Are you kidding me? I mean, I'm a 54-year-old man that is not living in a cave.
为什么我从来、从来没有听人说过威尔士语？这是一个金色的山洞。让我说，让我们诚实点。是的，一个美丽的山洞。上面没有任何标志。我听说过。说清楚点。是的。
Why have I never, ever heard Welsh spoken? It's a golden cave. Let me let's be honest. Yes, a beautiful cave. There's no sign to it. I've heard tell. Let's be clear. Yes.
一个山洞统御众生。为什么？什么？我不明白这怎么能从我身边溜走。为什么？好吧，我觉得，听听，我不想陷入抨击英国人的肥皂盒，但英国人，你知道，如果我们要做，我们来做一个简短的历史。英国人尽其所能地试图根除所有的凯尔特语言，
One cave to bind us all. Why? What? I don't understand how that's gone by me. Why do? Well, I think, listen, I don't want to get into on the English bashing soapbox, but the English, you know, if we're going to, we'll do the quick history. The English did their best to kind of eradicate all the Celtic languages
为了苏格兰人、爱尔兰人、威尔士人、康沃尔人。你知道，他们，他们，他们对凯尔特人不太友好。所以这里有很多对语言和文化的压制。哇。而且，它是否受到了北方人的影响，比如，所有这些凯尔特语言都有维京人的影响吗？我的意思是，我的意思是，伟大的演化者，基于日耳曼语。然后，你知道，我认为凯尔特人最初是一个西班牙部落，然后，
for the Scots, the Irish, the Welsh, the Cornish. You know, they, they, they weren't too Celtic friendly. So there was a lot of stamping out of the language in the culture. Wow. And, and was it influenced by folks more Northern, like, was there a Viking influence to all those Celtic languages? I mean, I mean, there's the great evolutionist, Germanic based. And then, you know, the, I think the Celtoi were a Spanish tribe initially, and they,
你知道，高卢人也参与进来了并融合了。然后，然后他们在不列颠建立营地，然后罗马人来了。我们在美国都是小婴儿吗？好吧，你什么也没学，即使你付出了注意，你知道，即使你在美国，去上学，不是在按摩公交车上，你，你，你学了，你学了历史。你怎么敢？你学了历史。
you know, then the Gauls got involved and amalgamated. And then, and then they set up Camping Britain and then the Romans came. Were all such babies here in America? Well, you don't learn any, even if you did pay attention, you know, even if you did in America, go to school, not on a massage bus, you, you, you learned, you learned, you learned history. How dare you? You learned history.
你知道的，然后高卢人卷入并融和了。然后，然后他们建立了不列颠露营地，接着罗马人来了。我们在美洲怎么都像些婴儿？好吧，你什么也没学到，即使你真的专心听讲了，你知道的，即使你在美洲上过学，不是在按摩巴士上，你、你、你学到了、学到了、学到了历史。你怎么敢？你学到了历史。
But at least in Canada, we did, we had to take British history. So we knew, oh, we're always talking about the fucking battle of Culloden and all that shit. Is the, is the, is the empire still stamped down your throat in Canada? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. I mean, I don't, I, I haven't lived there in 30 years. So I, I'm not sure. This is a guy who reads World War II books on the can, going to bed.
但至少在加拿大，我们是这样的，我们必须学英国历史。所以我们知道，哦，我们整天都在讨论他妈的卡洛登战役和那些乱七八糟的事。在加拿大，那种帝国主义色彩还是硬灌到你脑子里吗？哦，对，对，对，当然。我是说，我，我，我三十年前就离开那里了。所以，我，我不太确定。这家伙蹲坑时都在看二战的书，直到上床睡觉。
Yeah. It's not as bad as Justin Thoreau who will watch World War II documentaries through the face hole of a massage table on his iPhone. Okay. That's, he takes it to a new level, this, this lust for World War II. And he lines it just for comfort and stuff. He lines it with his discarded sleeves, just to protect his face. Just to pad the ring.
对。没那么糟，贾斯汀·特鲁多才过分呢，他会通过按摩床的面部孔洞，用iPhone看二战纪录片。好吧。他把对二战的这种狂热提升到了一个新的高度。而且他这么做纯粹是为了舒服什么的。他用自己不要的旧袖子垫在周围，只是为了保护脸。只是为了给那个洞垫个衬。
So, so Matthew, so you're, you're in, you're, what, you're sort of 17 and you go to Rada. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. One of the ones, yeah. One of the Academy of Dramatic Art in London, which is the preeminent classical acting school in the world. Yeah.
所以，所以马修，所以你，你当时在，你，什么，你大概17岁，然后你去了皇家戏剧艺术学院（Rada）。对。对。对。其中一个，对。伦敦皇家戏剧艺术学院，那是全世界最顶尖的古典表演学校。对。
I tell everyone. Yeah. I was what I've told my parents. They allow me to go. It's like everybody who goes to Rada, they'll tell you in the same way with everybody who's ever gone to Oxford, make sure to let that be known. Yes. We'll drop it in.
我逢人就说。对。我就是这么跟我父母说的。他们允许我去。就像所有去Rada的人一样，他们会告诉你，就像所有去过牛津大学的人一样，一定要让别人知道这一点。没错。我们会不经意地提出来。
You know, they're all called, you walk in and they've left the, the on the boards are still up in, in the, in the foyers. So like, you know, has Peter O'Toole and Antio Hopkins and it's incredible. I did a summer, I did a summer course there years ago. Did you? 1987. Yeah. Shakespeare?
你知道，他们都叫，你走进去，然后他们把，门厅的公告板上还挂着那些名字。所以就像，你知道，有彼得·奥图尔和安东尼·霍普金斯，太不可思议了。我很多年前在那里上过一个暑期班。是吗？1987年。对。莎士比亚？
Yeah. I did the whole thing for a few years there. At Rada. At Rada. I sure did. How was that? I was amazing, man. What did you do?
对。我在那里完整地读了好几年。在Rada。在Rada。我当然去了。感觉怎么样？太棒了，老兄。你都做了什么？
You seemed so dumb. It was amazing. Is there a lot of pressure when you go to a school like that to, to, to, to make it? I mean, obviously you did, but I mean, is there, it could just sort of culturally, do you feel there like, oh my God, okay, so I'm in Rada now. I got to, I got to, I got to, I got to maintain our, our batting average of, or is there a lot of people that go there and, and, and then go into other fields? Is that, is that more common?
你看起来太蠢了。太棒了。去这样的学校，会不会有很大的压力，要，要，要，要出人头地？我是说，显然后来你做到了，但我的意思是，有没有那种，从文化层面上讲，你在那里会觉得，哦天哪，好吧，我现在在Rada了。我得，我得，我得，我得保持我们的，我们的成材率，或者是不是有很多人去那里，然后，然后，然后转行去其他领域的？这，这更常见吗？
It is. It is. It's a, it's a very small intake. There's only 30 to each year. 15, 15 men, 15 women. Every year. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。这是一个，这是一个录取人数非常少的学校。每年只有30个人。15个男的，15个女的。每年。对。对。
So it's, it's very small. So you, you feel the pressure. Immediately. That's small. Did they do it on a bus? Yes. Like a massage bus. Yeah.
所以它，它非常小。所以你会，你会感受到压力。立刻就能感受到。那地方真小。他们是在公交车上上课吗？对。就像按摩车一样。对。
Yeah. It just, it just kind of goes around, around to Piccadilly Circus. We had 30 on the massage bus comfortably. That's what I heard. And then you got to stop, you got to stop for lunch at Jinkies on Ventura, right? Yeah. I mentioned that. Yeah.
对。它就，它就到处开，开到皮卡迪利广场。我们有30个人舒舒服服地坐在按摩车里。我听说就是这样的。然后你得停下来，你得在文图拉的Jinkies停下来吃午饭，对吧？对。我提过这个。对。
But it's very exclusive. But you, here you are, you're a kid from Cardiff with the, you're the only Welsh person in your year. Yes, I was, I was, I had a friend who was a year older and then Michael Sheen had just come through and kind of blazed a trail and was kind of, you know, setting the West End on fire. So, so there was this, you know, there was a, the, the flag of Wales is, is the dragon. So there was a kind of a dragon's firmly stamped as to, you know, the Welsh are resurging again.
但它是非常独家（精英化）的。但是，你来到了这里，你是一个来自加的夫的孩子，你是你们那一届唯一的威尔士人。是的，我是，我是，我有一个大我一年的朋友，然后迈克尔·辛刚刚从那里毕业，可以说是开辟了一条道路，并且有点，你知道的，让西区为之轰动。所以，所以这里有一个，你知道的，有一个，威尔士的旗帜是，是红龙。所以有一种龙的图腾深深地印在那里，你知道的，威尔士人又在崛起。
But, you know, like as a Hopkins, Anthony Hopkins was the, the chairman of the board at the time. So he beat in and out and he'd, he'd just done Shadowlands. So, you know, there was this, there was this great air that, you know, anything was, anything was possible really. I think, I think one of the things that the Welsh and Wales suffer from enormously is small person syndrome. And at that time, there was just this little bubble of, of a few, you know, Welsh people
但是，你知道的，就像霍普金斯一样，安东尼·霍普金斯当时是董事会主席。所以他进进出出，他刚拍完《影子大地》。所以，你知道的，有一种，有一种伟大的氛围，你知道的，任何事情，任何事情都是可能的。我认为，我认为威尔士人和威尔士遭受的巨大痛苦之一就是“小人物综合症”。而在那个时候，只有这么一小撮，你知道的，威尔士人
doing incredibly well, Catherine Zito was bursting to the ranks. So I was there at this renaissance when anything felt possible. You know what my question is going to be. I can ask it now or later. Oh, did you ever forget a line on stage? What's your favorite theater story, Matthews? Yeah, because you got to have one or two. Yes.
混得风生水起，凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯也崭露头角。所以我当时正处于这个文艺复兴时期，感觉一切皆有可能。你们知道我的问题会是什么。我现在问或者待会儿问都行。哦，你在舞台上忘过词吗？你最喜欢的剧场故事是什么，马修？对，因为你总得有一两个吧。是的。
I have, I have quite a few, in fact. No, but when I was, because I was doing theater for, for the first, well, five years solidly. And then at 25, I thought I, I, I got the role that was going to change my life and my career. It didn't. But I got to play Benjamin Braddock in a stage adaptation of The Graduate with Kathleen Turner as my Mrs. Robinson. Wow.
事实上，我，我有好几个。不，但是当我，因为我一直在演戏剧，连续演了五年。然后在25岁时，我想我，我，我得到了一个将改变我的人生和职业生涯的角色。虽然没能改变。但我有机会在舞台改编版的《毕业生》中扮演本杰明·布拉多克，凯瑟琳·特纳饰演我的鲁宾逊太太。哇。
And to me, it was the first real introduction to Hollywood because I'd never experienced anything like it in every sense. Like PAs and I was like, what's a PA? Who has a PA? It was just incredible. Anyway, fast forward, halfway through the run, it got a little, you know, there were a few bedroom antics in, in, in the production. And there's one moment where I jump in bed and we're simulating sex.
对我来说，这是我真正接触好莱坞的第一次经历，因为我在各方面都从未经历过这样的事情。比如制片助理（PA），当时我就想，什么是PA？谁会有PA？简直不可思议。不管怎样，快进到演出过半的时候，情况变得有点，你知道的，（剧组里）有一些卧室里的滑稽事。有那么一个瞬间，我要跳上床，我们在模拟性爱。
And I have to kind of plunge my face between her legs as if I'm, I'm pleasuring her. Sure. And she did have the, you know, the obligatory kind of, you know, flesh toned underwear on. But anyway, I had a, I had a streaming head cold. Sure. And being the malicious vindictive type that I am, I wouldn't let the end of study go on. So I went, I went on and I had my nose is just streaming, my cold, my nose is streaming.
我得把脸埋在她两腿之间，就好像我在，我在取悦她一样。当然。她确实穿着那种，你知道的，规定动作般的肉色内衣。但总之，我当时得了严重的重感冒。没错。而且出于我这种恶毒又记仇的性格，我可不会让演出泡汤。所以我上台了，当时我的鼻子一直在流鼻涕，我的感冒，我的鼻子一直在流。
And I couldn't, I didn't want to kind of sniff heavily during, you know, during. So I, and I'm, yeah, I go, oh, I know what I, I know what I, I know what I'll do. I'll just clear my nose in that quiet moment when I'm between. I know. And I didn't think. So I jumped in and I'm between Miss Turner's legs and I just went and inhaled deeply and the covers kind of shot up and she's looking down at me like, what the fuck, what the fuck are you doing?
而且我忍不住，我不想在（演出的）时候大声吸鼻涕，你知道的，在那个期间。所以，我，我当时想，哦，我知道我，我知道我，我知道我该怎么做了。我只会在那个安静的时刻，在我俩中间的时候，顺一顺我的鼻子。我懂的。我当时没多想。所以我跳上床，在特纳女士的两腿之间，我直接就，深深地吸了一口气，然后被子突然弹了起来，她低头看着我，那眼神仿佛在说：他妈的，你他妈在干什么？
And I was like, oh, oh, no, I'm not, no, I'm not, I'm not sniffing, I'm not sniffing. I have a cold. I have a cold, I'm not sniffing you. You're not trying to whine out. Yeah. No, no. My God. No way.
当时我就想：哦，哦，不，我不是，不，我不是，我不是在吸鼻涕，我不是在吸鼻涕。我感冒了。我感冒了，我不是在吸你。你不是在故意占便宜。对。不，不。天哪。绝不可能。
That's that. I always live with this deep regret of that moment, that and when someone, there was a paparazzi photo, when the moment she took off her robe and this paparazzi photo, I stood up and photographed her and a big flash went off. I know. Oh, Lord. And I looked at her on stage in this moment and I was like, oh, we should, we should stop. And she came in with the next line and I always remember thinking, regardless that she
就是这样。那一刻的遗憾一直萦绕在我心头，还有那次，当有狗仔队拍照时，就在她脱下长袍的那一刻，这张狗仔队的照片，我站起来拍她，然后闪光灯“咔嚓”闪了一下。我懂的。哦，天哪。当时我在舞台上看着她，心想：哦，我们应该，我们应该停下来。然后她接上了下一句台词，我一直记得当时的想法是：不管她
was a consumer professional, I'm going to come in with the next line, I'm going to carry on. I bitterly regret in that moment not stopping the production because the next day in a tabloid newspaper, there was a huge photograph of, yeah, yeah, I was ashamed. I was ashamed. Oh my God. Well, you know. But it was.
是一位职业素养极高的演员，我要接上下一句台词，我要继续演下去。我无比后悔当时没有叫停演出，因为第二天的小报上登出了一张巨幅照片，里面有，对，对，我很羞耻。我太羞耻了。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道的。但那可是。
It's a tabloid and the headline just said, Welshman, you know, just fucking cowers under pressure. Yeah, yeah, yes, spineless Welshman does nothing. We'll leave it to the English tabloids to say that. Yeah. I love that. Oh my God. So Matthew, so you did, as you said, you did, did you play another great Welshman?
那是小报，头条直接写着：“威尔士人，你知道的，在压力下像个他妈的懦夫一样退缩了。”对，对，是的，没骨气的威尔士人什么都不敢做。这种话也就英国小报说得出口。对。我太喜欢这个了。哦，天哪。所以马修，所以你做了，就像你说的，你做过，你演过另一个伟大的威尔士人吗？
You played Dylan Thomas, didn't you? I did. At one point? I did. That, yes. Oh my God, it feels so long ago. It was about 12 years ago now, yeah. He had this incredible moment, the poet Dylan Thomas had this incredible moment in his
你演过迪伦·托马斯，对吧？我演过。曾经？我演过。对，是的。哦，天哪，感觉像是好久以前的事了。大概是12年前了，对。诗人迪伦·托马斯在他的
life where he was having an affair, that power was played by Keira Knightley and Ternan Miller was playing my wife, and Killian Murphy is the husband of Keira Knightley, and this is all true, that he burst in on Dylan Thomas with a machine gun because he was doing the Second War. He came in with a machine gun, he opened fire, he, like, and then missed everyone and took out a grenade, pulled the pin, and the grenade didn't go off, and it was that story that we told in. No way.
生活中有过这样一段不可思议的经历，当时他有一段婚外情，那个角色由凯拉·奈特莉扮演，西娜·米勒饰演我的妻子，而基里安·墨菲是凯拉·奈特莉的丈夫，这一切都是真的，他拿着机关枪冲向迪伦·托马斯，因为他当时在打二战。他拿着机枪冲进来，开火，他，就像是，结果打偏了所有人，然后掏出一颗手榴弹，拉开插销，结果手榴弹没炸，我们讲述的就是这样一个故事。绝无可能。
The image of love. Yeah, it was kind of, it was an unbelievable story that he survived, and then tragically drank himself to death. Wow, talk about the worst assassin you could ever imagine. Yes, and I was like, I was talking to Killian about it, I was like, but you're playing, you're a commando, you're a trained commando, do you want to play this part? So you are, you are not, you do not live in Wales, correct? I do not, no.
爱的意象。是的，这简直是个难以置信的故事，他竟然活了下来，然后悲剧的是酗酒而死。哇，可以说是你能想象到的最糟糕的刺客了。是的，当时我还在跟基里安聊这个，我说：但你演的是，你是个突击队员，是个受过训练的突击队员，你想演这个角色吗？所以你，你不是，你不住在威尔士，对吧？我不住，没有。
I now live in leafy Brooklyn. Leafy Brooklyn. No, you live in Brooklyn, but you come over, you do theatre, as you say, for basically five years, and then you move over to America to do what, what was the first thing that brought you over? The first thing I did, I was doing a play, I was actually doing a two-hander draw court with Paul Betteney called One More Wasted Year, and everyone called it One More Wasted Evening because it wasn't good, my own family said as much, it was terrible.
我现在住在绿树成荫的布鲁克林。绿树成荫的布鲁克林。不，你住在布鲁克林，但你会过来，你演戏剧，正如你所说，基本上演了五年，然后你搬到了美国去干嘛，带你过来的第一部作品是什么？我做的第一件事是演一出戏，我其实在皇家宫廷剧院和保罗·贝坦尼合作过一出只有两个人的戏，叫《又一个被浪费的年头》（One More Wasted Year），每个人都把它叫作《又一个被浪费的夜晚》（One More Wasted Evening），因为这戏实在不咋地，我家人自己都这么说，太烂了。
So they come backstage, what were they saying to you backstage? My uncle was the first person of the entire group and they came in and he's an old sea captain, very salty, and he went, well, that was shit. Yeah. And I couldn't argue, I went, you're absolutely right. And then, yeah, Stephen Daldry, who was the, Stephen Daldry was the artistic director at the time, and Prestonite came in, went, darlings, was it the play we need to see right now? Probably not.
所以他们来到后台，他们在后台对你说了什么？我叔叔是所有人当中第一个开口的，他们走进来，他是一个老船长，非常老练泼辣，他说：“嗯，那玩意儿真他妈是个垃圾。”对。而我无言以对，我说：“您说的太对了。”然后，史蒂芬·戴德利，当时他是，史蒂芬·戴德利当时是艺术总监，还有普雷斯顿ite走了进来，说道：“亲爱的们，这是我们现在需要看的戏吗？大概不是吧。”
Should we go to a party? There's hysterical. Wow, that's so hardcore. So you come over with Paul Betteney, you do that. Sorry, yes. An American agent came to see the play and he said, do you want to come over for pilot season? And I had no idea what it was.
“我们要去参加派对吗？”简直太搞笑了吧。哇，太硬核了。所以你和保罗·贝坦尼一起来的美国，你演了那个。抱歉，是的。一个美国经纪人来看了这出戏，他说：“你想不想来（洛杉矶）试镜季碰碰运气？”我当时根本不知道那是什么。
And I said, yes. And then came to LA. And then the first audition he set me up with, it was Julie Tamer's first movie Titus with Antony Hopkins and Jessica Lange, and I just thought, oh my God, Los Angeles is truly the promised land where you just turn up and get these huge movies and everything's great. Yeah, you just signed up. And then I did that.
我说：“好啊。”然后就来了洛杉矶。结果他给我安排的第一次试镜，是朱莉·泰莫的处女作电影《提图斯》，由安东尼·霍普金斯和杰西卡·兰格主演，我当时就想：哦，天哪，洛杉矶真的是人间乐园，只要你随便一出现就能接到这样的大制作电影，一切都太棒了。对，你直接就签约了。然后我就拍了那部。
Yeah. And I shot that in Rome for six months, and then I went back to LA and didn't get a job for a decade. Yeah. So here's another time I'm going to, my career's going to be made, and it was just like, eh, we're just paid a few bills. Isn't that amazing? Isn't that, I love that feeling of like, yeah, it's going to be like this forever.
对。我在罗马拍了六个月，然后回到洛杉矶，接着有十年没接到工作。对。所以又是一个这样的时刻，我觉得我的职业生涯要起飞了，结果却是：呃，我们只是勉强付得起账单。这难道不神奇吗？难道不，我太喜欢那种感觉了，就好像：对，以后都会这样的。
Yeah, yeah. It's like the Klondike, I arrived, it was like the Klondike, where they throw you these scripts and go, this is being made for MGM, with this as the lead, and you're like, oh my, and you're allowing me to audition for this? This is madness. Yeah. All I have to do is get the part, and I'm set for life. You never know anything.
对，对。就像克ondike（淘金热），我刚到的时候，就像克朗代克淘金热一样，他们把这些剧本扔给你，说：“这是为米高梅制作的，由某某担任主角，”而你就会想：哦，天哪，你们竟然允许我来试镜这个？这太疯狂了。对。我只要拿到这个角色，这辈子就衣食无忧了。你永远猜不到会发生什么。
You really don't. I mean, look at us three morons. Like, each of us have had great success as I knock on wood. We're super grateful for it in our careers. But then, you know, this thing comes along, it's more successful than anything we've ever done. And it was just us three, and it's chatting during COVID. Right.
你真的猜不到。我是说，看看我们这三个笨蛋。就像，我们每个人都取得了巨大的成功，敲木头（求吉利）。我们对职业生涯中的这一切充满感激。但随后，你知道的，这个项目出现了，它比我们做过的任何事情都要成功。而且当时只有我们三个，在疫情期间聊天。对吧。
What would you know? And the world basically was saying, we don't want you guys to do the thing that you think that you're going to just tell. The things you're pre-professional at. Yeah, you can keep doing that a little bit if you want. But we just want you to be that you're, we want to hear your idiotic thoughts on stupid shit. Yeah.
你能知道什么？而全世界基本上都在说：我们不想让你们去做那些你们以为自己最擅长的专业事情。那些你们专业领域的事。对，如果你想的话，你可以稍微继续做一点那种。但我们只想让你们成为你们自己，我们想听你们对各种蠢事的弱智看法。对。
Just like, you know, wonder at the moment where Sean learns that Whales was, you know why, you know where Whales got its name, Sean? That's where they made the first harpoon, you know? That's not true. That's not true. It's not true. That's not true. Correct.
就像，你知道的，回想肖恩得知威尔士时的那一刻，你知道为什么，你知道威尔士是怎么得名的吗，肖恩？那是他们制造第一支鱼叉的地方，你知道吗？这不是真的。这不是真的。这不是真的。这不是真的。完全正确。
And that's what they tune in to hear. Because he'll fuck with me and he'll say something that's completely not true and then he'll say something that's completely true and never know what to believe. It's tough. I'm fine knowing. But wait a minute. They did shoot Moby Dick in Whales with Gregory Peck and my grandfather worked on it. Is that true?
而这正是他们收听节目的原因。因为他会跟我开玩笑，说一些完全不着边际的话，然后又会说一些完全真实的话，让你永远不知道该相信哪一个。这太难了。我倒是很清楚。但等一下。他们确实在威尔士拍摄过《白鲸》，由格里高利·派克主演，我外公还在那里面工作过。真的吗？
Is that true? Yeah, they built three large rubber Whales and one of them, I know, this is a great joke is like they came to Whales and one of them sailed off into the Irish Sea, which I think is fantastic that there was this. I have a whale that needs a rubber, but go ahead. Hello. My grandfather caught Moby Dick, but there's a cue for it now. Wait, wait, what did your grandfather do on that?
真的吗？对，他们建造了三头巨大的橡胶鲸鱼，其中一头，我知道，这是一个很棒的笑话，他们来到威尔士，其中一头竟然漂流到了爱尔兰海，我觉得这太棒了，竟然有这种事。我有一头需要橡胶的鲸鱼，不过你继续。你好。我外公抓过白鲸，不过现在得排队了。等等，等等，你外公在那部电影里做什么？
His friend, Edgar, was a carpenter and they kind of helped out and I think in the framing of the Whales. I love that. Yeah. That's cool. Wait, I want to ask about Kerry and I want to know like did you meet each other, because I'm an idiot. I don't know.
他的朋友埃德加是个木匠，他们去帮忙了，我记得好像是参与了鲸鱼骨架的搭建。我喜欢这个。对。太酷了。等等，我想问关于凯莉的事，我想知道你们是怎么认识的，因为我是个大笨蛋。我不知道。
Did you meet before Americans or on the set and how did that go? And when did you know the sparks flow? Just one question at a time. We did. Because I get easily confused. Because I love Kerry. I love Kerry. So do I.
你们是在来美国之前认识的，还是在片场认识的？过程怎么样？你们是怎么知道爱情的火花被点燃的？一个问题一个问题来。好嘞。因为我很容易糊涂。因为我爱凯莉。我爱凯莉。我也是。
We met quite a few years before the Americans in Rustic Canyon at a kickball party that Jennifer Gray hosted and I had no idea what kickball was. Boy, all of that adds up, by the way. Yes, yes. How I just amble through life, bumping into the furniture and ending up going, how did I get here, how did this happen? And we were the last two to leave, we were in the parking lot and I was trying to open a bottle of beer for her with a key and failing and I asked for her number then.
我们在《美国谍梦》开拍好几年前就在鲁斯蒂峡谷（Rustic Canyon）认识了，那是詹妮弗·加灰（Jennifer Grey）举办的一个踢球派对，我当时根本不知道踢球是什么。天哪，所有的线索现在都对上了。对，对。我是怎么跌跌撞撞地度过一生，撞到各种家具，最后却说：我是怎么到这里的，这一切是怎么发生的？我们是最后两个离开的，我们在停车场，我试图用钥匙帮她打开一瓶啤酒，结果失败了，于是我那时向她要了电话号码。
And then, and that was all I can remember. She was moving to New York two days after that on the Tuesday, it was a Sunday. And that's all I still remember. And then the road to the Americans was a long, crazy one. And then on the first day of fight training, I said to Kerry, I said, oh, we've met, we've met before, actually. And she was like, no, no, we definitely haven't. I've sort of been years.
然后，然后，这就是我能记住的全部了。她在那之后的两天（周二）就要搬去纽约了，当时是周日。这就是我至今还记得的全部。后来到了《美国谍梦》的片场，那是一段漫长而疯狂的经历。然后在武术训练的第一天，我对凯莉说：“哦，我们其实，我们以前见过。”而她的反应是：“不，不，我们绝对没见过。我已经好多年……”
He's been years at this point. And I said, yeah, yeah, we met before, we met at a kickball party in Rustic Canyon. She went, I know who you are, and you left me a message on my answering machine, a very drunken message. And I went, oh, did I, did I, I'm so sorry. I have no memory of leaving a long, rambling, incoherent, drunken message, which is probably what she wrote. No way.
此时已经过去好多年了。我说：“对，对，我们以前见过，我们在鲁斯蒂峡谷的一个踢球派对上见过。”她回答：“我知道你是谁，你还在我的答录机上留过言，一条非常醉醺醺的留言。”我说：“哦，我有吗，我有吗？真的非常抱歉。”我完全不记得自己留过一条又长、又语无伦次、醉醺醺的留言，这可能正是她所写的。绝无可能。
Did you really? Wait, can I, can I be a super moron? Are you guys together? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Wait, did you, so you got together, you started working together.
你真的留过？等等，我可以，我可以当一个超级大笨蛋吗？你们俩是在一起吗？对。对。对。好吧。等等，所以你们在一起了，你们开始合作了。
They were just bringing up that they're just good friends. Well, no, because they worked together on the Americans for six years. That's what I'm saying. That's what I was asking. That's correct. But then, but during that, you guys fell in love, got married, had a kid. We did. And I want to know what happened.
他们之前只是提起说他们是好朋友。好吧，没有，因为他们在《美国谍梦》里合作了六年。这就是我要问的。这就是我想问的。没错。但随后，但在那期间，你们俩坠入爱河，结婚，还有了孩子。我们确实如此。我想知道后来发生了什么。
So she goes, oh, okay, now I remember you. And then what? And then it was, it was just a very, it was a very slow burn. The first season, you know, I think we were both trying to be sworn off to that thing where you're going to go, I'm not going to do what everyone tells us never to do. I'm not going to do that. And then, but the beginning of the second season, it was, it was, it was, it was, yeah. Super sale.
所以她说：“哦，好吧，现在我记起你是谁了。”然后呢？然后就是，那是一个非常，那是一个非常慢热的过程。第一季的时候，你知道的，我觉得我们俩都试图克制自己，不去卷入那种大家都告诫你千万别做的事。我才不要那样做。然后，但到了第二季刚开始的时候，那就，那就，那就，真是干柴烈火。
Oh wait, it's okay. So now, were the producer, did the producers take each of you aside individually and say, hey, this is, you're dealing with an asset here. Okay. Everyone has jobs. If you guys go south, we have to shut the show down. Was it, were there conversations? No, no, they were very gracious about it because I've had friends, I know, I've had friends
哦等等，没关系。所以现在，制作人，制片人有没有把你们俩分别叫到一边，说：“嘿，这是，你们这可是在处理一笔资产啊。”好吧。每个人都有工作。如果你们俩黄了，我们这剧就得停播了。有过这种对话吗？没有，没有，他们对此非常宽容，因为我有朋友，我知道，我有过这样的朋友
who, you know, who've had that conversation to sit down from the producers going, look, we've all been down here before. You guys are in your mid thirties now, the, you know, you're not 22. Right off the company. And they were very, yeah, they were very kind of gracious about it. Do you know, do you know the TV director, Tommy Slamy? Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
他们，你知道的，经历过这种对话，制片人坐下来对他们说：“听着，这种事我们以前都经历过。你们现在都三十多岁了，你知道的，你们不再是22岁了。”直接离开公司。而他们对此非常，对，非常宽容。你知道，你知道电视导演托马斯·斯拉米（Thomas Schlamme）吗？对，对。对。
So, Slamy was directing the beginning of the second season and he has that kind of beautiful voice. But Kerry and I were having a, we were doing a sex scene and Slamy just goes, these two have been naked together before. And then we just, it was like, called out. Oh really? Mr. Slamy. So at that point no one knew, but he could tell.
所以，斯拉米当时在执导第二季的开拍，他有那种动听的嗓音。但当时我和凯莉正在拍一场性爱戏，斯拉米直接就说：“这两个人以前赤诚相见的时候可不是这样的。”然后我们就被，就像是被当场抓包了。哦真的吗？斯拉米先生。所以当时没有人知道，但他能看出来。
He could, he could tell them. And then there's a longer story as to how we got found out, which was just. We've got time. Well, Kerry got broken into, I was in the house, I was in the house at the time and the, and the robbers kind of grabbed my backpack, shoved it full of her stuff. You're in the house alone during a home invasion. Yeah. Yeah.
他能，他能看出来。然后关于我们是怎么暴露的，还有一段更长、更搞笑的故事，那就是……我们有的是时间。好吧，凯莉家遭了小偷，我当时就在屋里，我在屋里呢，然后，然后劫匪顺手抓走我的背包，塞满了她的东西。你在家的时候遭遇了入室盗窃。对。对。
Well, start there. Well, so here's the other thing is it's early day and this is, this is just a testament to my abject stupidity. But with early days of our, of our relationship and she wakes me up, she says, there's someone in the house and I go, no, there's not. And then I just heard this voice and I remember, and I remember thinking in any logical moment you'd go, let's lock ourselves in the bathroom, call 911 and for some stupid reason, because it was very early days, I thought, what I do next, right, she will judge me on for the
好吧，从这开始讲。好吧，还有一件事，那是刚开始交往的时候，这简直证明了我极致的愚蠢。那是我们关系的早期阶段，她把我摇醒，说：“屋里有人。”而我说：“不，没有。”然后我听到一个声音，我记得，我当时想，任何有逻辑的人在这个时候都会想：我们应该把自己反锁在浴室里，拨打911。但出于某种愚蠢的原因，因为当时我们正处于恋爱初期，我想：我接下来要做的事，对，她会以此来评判我的一生。
rest of our lives. Have you, what's that? Um, film? Force, for sure. Force, for sure. Yeah. The avalanche comes and he just runs. He leaves his family behind.
你看过那个吗？嗯……电影？《游客》（Force Majeure），绝对是。《游客》。对。雪崩来的时候他直接就跑了。他把家人抛在身后。
Right. Right. I was like, if I suggest to go into the bathroom and call 911, will she think me a coward? Right. Your relationship's over. Yes. I had all these weird things going through my head. So what did I do?
对。对。我当时想：如果我建议去浴室躲起来并拨打911，她会认为我是个懦夫吗？对。那你们的感情就完了。是的。我脑子里闪过各种奇怪的念头。所以我做了什么？
She had a, she had a working fireplace in the, in the, in the bedroom, so I picked up the poker and with not a stitch on me, I walked out to meet my fate. Oh God. Wow. And we'll be right back after these messages. Okay. So now we're back. So now we're back.
她的卧室里有一个，有一个可以使用的壁炉，所以我拿起了火钳，一丝不挂地走了出去，去迎接我的命运。哦天哪。哇。广告之后马上回来。好吧。现在我们回来了。现在我们回来了。
So now you're, now, now you're- So after eight months of treatment, yes. No. I was fine. No, I'm kidding. So, so did you face to face with this fella? No. Because what I did was the, I think what most people do is you turn the light on, light
所以现在你，现在，现在你——所以经过八个月的治疗，对。没有。我挺好的。不，开玩笑的。所以，所以你和这家伙面对面了吗？没有。因为我做的，我想大多数人都会这么做，你把灯打开，灯
on and they run straight away. Right. So I heard them kind of run and, and they ran it, they ran out the front door. Oh, thank God. I know. I know. Jesus. So you do this and now Carrie thinks that you're her hero.
一亮，他们立刻就逃跑了。对。所以我听到他们好像在跑，然后，他们从前门逃跑了。哦，谢天谢地。我知道。我知道。天哪。所以你这么做了，现在凯莉觉得你是她的英雄。
Yeah. I wouldn't go that far. Or did she think you were stupid for chasing her? Yeah. Yeah, basically. Yeah. She was locked in the bathroom. Yeah.
对。我不会说得那么过分。或者她觉得你追出去的行为很蠢？对。对，基本上是这样。对。她把自己反锁在浴室里。对。
Calling 9.1. Calling 9.1. Yeah. Then seven cops turn up and they start, they clock her and they're like looking, they love no idea who I am, but they're looking at her and then, and then all of a sudden the DA were like, they catch them and the DA said, Oh, I tell you what, we would love to return your belongings on set with a photographer to Carrie, if that's okay. And she's like, she wasn't wild about the idea, tried to pull her off.
拨打911。拨打911。对。然后七个警察赶到现场，他们开始盘问她，打量着她，他们根本不知道我是谁，但他们看着她，然后，突然地方检察官说：哦，这样吧，如果我们能带着摄影师把你们失窃的物品送回片场给凯莉，如果这可以的话。而她当时说：她对这个主意其实不太感冒，试图推脱掉。
I don't know, cause the DA was retiring that year, wanted kind of a, you know, hero ending. So the NYPD, come on set with a photographer and then they're holding up my bag and Yedid, one of the young PAs went, wait, that's not Carrie's bag, that's Matthew's bag. And as I'm running, trying to go, shut the fuck up, and that's how the crew kind of found out. No. Wow. Wow.
我不知道，因为那年地方检察官快退休了，想要一个，你知道的，英雄式的收尾。所以纽约警察局带着摄影师来到片场，然后他们举起我的包，耶迪（Yedid），其中一个年轻的PA说：“等等，那不是凯莉的包，那是马修的包。”而当时我正跑过去试图制止：“闭上你他妈的嘴！”剧组就是这样发现的。不。哇。哇。
Wow. So arbitrary. Yeah. Wow. That's kind of cool. So then this guy managed to grab a few things before he went running. He did. He did.
哇。太巧合了。对。哇。那挺酷的。所以这个家伙逃跑前还顺走了几样东西。他确实拿了。他拿了。
He did. And when I saw the picture of him, when he was arrested, I said, Oh, I said, look, there's a picture of the guy they caught him. I said, look, look, and he's been cuffed by two little tiny cops. She said, they're not tiny. And I saw this, oh my, I saw the size of him. He could have, he could have turned me into a kebab with that poker and done what he wanted. I wouldn't have had a.
他拿了。当我看到他被捕时的照片时，我说：“哦，我说，看，这是他们抓到那家伙的照片，你看，你看，他被两个小不点警察拷上了。”她说：“他们可不小。”然后我看到了这个，哦天哪，我看到了他的体型。他完全可以，他完全可以用那根火钳把我做成烤肉串，然后随心所欲。我当时连……
Now, did you have any sort of war cry as you turned on the light? Was there any sort of? No. Hey, bear. Hey, bear. Yeah. You know, was there any of that? No, no, as much as that, as much as I have a poker.
那你打开灯的时候，有没有发出什么战吼？有什么类似于这种的声音吗？没有。嘿，熊。嘿，熊。对。你知道的，有那种声音吗？没有，没有，尽管我有火钳。
Yeah. Yeah. As much as I love that moment in Gladiator and all the Celts kind of attack the Romans. And I always think, you know, if it came to it, that's how I'd react. I was not, I couldn't move my legs. Don't make me come down there. Yeah. I'm classically trained.
对。对。尽管我很喜欢《角斗士》里的那一幕，所有凯尔特人一起冲向罗马人。我总是想，如果真的到了那一步，我就会那样反应。但我当时，我的双腿动弹不得。别逼我下来。对。我可是受过正经训练的。
You know what? I'm fencing. Totally naked. Yes. Let's, let's get this going. Yeah. And we will be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by Element.
你知道吗？我会击剑。而且一丝不挂。对。让我们，让我们开始吧。对。我们马上回来。本集部分内容由Element赞助播出。
We all kind of know how important electrolytes are, right? They replenish us. They give us energy. It's important so you don't get dehydrated. This can be after having a few cocktails or working out, keeping an active lifestyle, etc. Element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix with everything you need and nothing you don't. That means lots of salt with no sugar.
我们都知道电解质有多重要，对吧？它们能补充我们的水分。它们给我们能量。这对于防止脱水至关重要。这可能发生在喝了几杯鸡尾酒之后，或者在锻炼、保持积极的生活方式等之后。Element是一种美味的电解质饮料混合物，含有你所需要的一切，而没有你不需要的东西。这意味着大量的盐，而且不含糖。
It contains a science-backed electrolyte ratio, 1,000 milligrams of sodium, 200 milligrams of potassium, and 60 milligrams of magnesium. So when you sweat, the primary electrolyte lost is sodium. Athletes can lose up to seven grams per day. When sodium isn't replaced, it's common to experience muscle cramps and fatigue. So with Element, you can help prevent and eliminate headaches, muscle cramps, fatigue, sleeplessness, and other common symptoms of electrolyte deficiency. So for me, I sweat every single day on stage.
它包含经科学证实的电解质比例：1000毫克钠、200毫克钾和60毫克镁。所以当你出汗时，流失的主要电解质就是钠。运动员每天可以流失多达七克。如果不补充钠，很容易出现肌肉痉挛和疲劳。因此，有了Element，你可以帮助预防和消除头痛、肌肉痉挛、疲劳、失眠以及电解质缺乏的其他常见症状。对我来说，我每天在舞台上都会出汗。
I'm on stage for about an almost two hours. I don't stop talking. You don't stop moving. I don't stop. Just, it's like a workout every day on Broadway. And it's like you're, my whole costume is drenched in sweat. So what I do is take a packet of one of my favorite flavors, put it in some water, and I down that water, taste delicious, feel great afterwards.
我在舞台上大约待将近两个小时。我嘴巴没停过。你一直在动。我一直没停。这就好象每天在百老汇进行一次锻炼。而且这就好像，我的整套戏服都被汗水湿透了。所以我要做的就是拿一包我最喜欢的口味，把它倒进水里，然后一饮而尽，味道好极了，之后感觉棒极了。
And it replenishes my whole body with electrolyte. There's lemon habanero, which is really great. There's raspberry salt. The one I love is watermelon salt. And I just tried orange salt. It's really, really, really delicious. Right now, Element is offering listeners a free sample pack with any purchase. That's eight single serving packets free with any Element order.
它为我的全身补充了电解质。有柠檬哈瓦那辣椒味，真的很棒。有覆盆子盐味。我最喜欢的是西瓜盐味。我还刚尝了橙子盐味。真的，真的，真的非常好喝。现在，Element为听众提供随任何购买赠送免费样品包的优惠。任何Element订单都可免费获赠八个单份包装。
This is a great way to try all eight flavors or share Element with a salty friend. Get yours at drinkelement.com slash smartlist. This deal is only available through our link. Go to drinklment.com slash smartlist. Element offers no questions asked refunds. Try it totally risk-free. If you don't like it, share it with a salty friend and they'll give your money back. No questions asked.
这是尝试所有八种口味或与喜欢咸味的朋友分享Element的绝佳方式。请访问drinkelement.com/smartlist获取你的专属优惠。此优惠仅通过我们的链接提供。访问drinklment.com/smartlist。Element提供无条件退款保证。完全无风险地尝试。如果你不喜欢，可以把它分享给喜欢咸味的朋友，他们会把钱退给你。无需任何多问。
You have nothing to lose. This episode is brought to you in part by Eight Sleep. Hey guys, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? Science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by Eight Sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet.
你没有什么可失去的。本集部分内容由Eight Sleep赞助。嘿，伙计们，你们知道温度是提高睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？科学研究表明，在睡眠的前期和中期，你的体温实际上需要下降，而在早晨需要上升，这样你才能快速入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。Eight Sleep的Pod套件像床单一样适合任何床垫。
The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. It can cool down and warm up and adjusts based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in. So for me and for like a lot of people, right, we sleep like one leg out, one leg in. I try to like sleep with covers off the top part of my body and just try to like figure out that perfect temperature to fall asleep in. So I sometimes achieve that perfect temp, but most times I don't.
Pod套件将通过根据你和伴侣的个人需求自动调节床铺两侧的温度来改善你的睡眠。它可以冷却和加热，并根据你的睡眠阶段和所处的环境进行调整。所以对我来说，就像很多人一样，对吧，我们睡觉时总是一条腿露在外面，一条腿缩在被子里。我试着睡觉时把被子盖在身体上半部分，试图找出入睡的完美温度。所以我有时能达到那个完美的温度，但大多数时候不能。
So that's why I'm super, super excited to try pod cover by Eight Sleep. I can't wait to see how it works. I've heard it's going to be great for my mental health, the quality of life because sleep is everything. So I'm really, really excited to try it because I can't wait to see like how sound I sleep and get that temperature just right. While temperature is the biggest game changer, the pod cover does have other amazing features. For example, thanks to the pod sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized
这就是为什么我超级，超级兴奋地想尝试Eight Sleep的Pod套件。我迫不及待地想看看它是如何工作的。我听说这对我的心理健康、生活质量大有裨益，因为睡眠就是一切。所以我真的，真的很兴奋去尝试，因为我迫不及待地想看看我的睡眠有多深，并且把温度调得恰到好处。虽然温度是最具颠覆性的改变，但Pod套件确实还有其他惊人的功能。例如，多亏了Pod的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都可以醒来看到一份个性化的
sleep report for you each morning that offers insights and how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine or whatever impact your sleep and overall health. Just in the rest you deserve with the Eight Sleep pod, go to eightsleep.com slash smart list for exclusive Memorial Day savings on the pod cover through June 6th. Stay cool this summer with Eight Sleep. Now shipping within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU and Australia. Our next partner is Athletic Greens. I take AG1 by Athletic Greens literally every day.
睡眠报告，其中提供了深入见解，说明深夜锻炼或咖啡因等某些行为如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康。使用Eight Sleep Pod享受你应得的良好休息，请访问eightsleep.com/smartlist，在6月6日之前享受Pod套件的独家阵亡将士纪念日优惠。今年夏天用Eight Sleep保持凉爽。现已发货至美国、加拿大、英国、欧盟部分国家和澳大利亚。我们的下一个合作伙伴是Athletic Greens。我真的每天都喝Athletic Greens的AG1。
I gave AG1 a try, I don't know, two years ago, maybe I wanted better gut health. I want more energy. I wanted a simple way to take vitamins and minerals that were important to my body. I didn't want to have to take all these supplements. I wanted one place and AG1 is that place. I put it in the thing, I shake the thing, I down the thing and it's so good for my body and it tastes great. This is the best option for easy optimal nutrition out there.
我尝试AG1大概是，我不知道，两年前吧，当时我想要更好的肠胃健康。我想要更多精力。我想要一种简单的方法来摄取对我的身体重要的维生素和矿物质。我不想吃所有这些补剂。我想要一个一站式解决的方案，而AG1就是那个方案。我把它放进杯子里，摇一摇，然后一饮而尽，这对我的身体太好了，而且味道好极了。这是获得简单且最佳营养的最佳选择。
You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, whole food source, superfoods, probiotics and adaptogens to help you start your day right. This blend of ingredients supports your gut health, your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, recovery, focus and aging. You know what I love most about it? You can mix it with water when you're traveling. You can put it in a smoothie like with all the other stuff that you make your smoothies with and it tastes great.
你只需要取一勺AG1，就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、全食物来源的超级食物、益生菌和适应原，帮助你以最佳状态开启新的一天。这种成分组合支持你的肠胃健康、神经系统、免疫系统、能量、恢复、注意力和抗衰老。你知道我最喜欢它什么吗？你可以在旅行时把它和水混在一起。你可以把它放进冰沙里，就像你制作冰沙的所有其他材料一样，味道很棒。
It tastes great any way you want to roll. I mean it's the healthiest way to start your day for me and I know it will be for you too. Right now it's time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop of AG1 and a cup of water every day. You don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health. Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one year supply of immune supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartlist to give AG1 a try.
无论你想要什么方式，它的味道都很好。我的意思是，对我和我知道的你来说，这是开启一天最健康的方式。现在是时候重塑你的健康，用便捷的日常营养武装你的身体了。每天只需一勺AG1和一杯水。你不需要成百上千种不同的药丸和补剂来照顾你的健康。Athletic Greens将在你的首次购买中为你提供一年的免费免疫支持维生素D和五包免费旅行装。访问athleticgreens.com/smartlist来试用AG1。
That's athleticgreens.com slash smartlist. Check it out. And now back to the show. All right, so you and Kerry have a child. That's a boy or a girl? He's a boy. He's a boy. Kerry has two older ones.
网址是athleticgreens.com/smartlist。快去看看吧。现在回到节目中。好吧，所以你和凯莉有个孩子。那是男孩还是女孩？是个男孩。是个男孩。凯莉还有两个大一点的孩子。
So there's three. You know, there's three in the house who outnumber us. And what are the ages of all three? 15, 11 and six. Wow. 15, 11 and six. Yeah. Then the 15 and 11 or boy girl?
所以有三个。你知道的，家里有三个孩子，他们在人数上超过了我们。这三个孩子的年龄分别是多大？15岁、11岁和6岁。哇。15岁、11岁和6岁。对。那15岁和11岁的是男孩还是女孩？
A boy girl. It's a boy girl boy. Boy girl boy. Yeah. And how are you liking being a dad? I love it. You love it? I do love it.
一个男孩一个女孩。是一个男孩、一个女孩、一个男孩。男孩女孩男孩。对。你觉得当爸爸感觉怎么样？我很喜欢。你很喜欢？我真的很喜欢。
It's the madness that I love. It's when it's at its most catastrophe. The small stuff irks you, but when it's catastrophic, it's brilliant. Yeah. When those mornings, when the wheels so royally come off, that's when I can sit back and go, oh, this is just brilliant. Who's the more patient one with all of the, with the chaos? Is it you or her?
我喜欢那种疯狂的感觉。当它处于最灾难性的状态时。小事情会惹恼你，但当事情变得一团糟时，这就太棒了。对。那些早上，当事情彻底乱套的时候，正是我可以靠在椅背上说：哦，这太棒了。在应对所有混乱时，谁更有耐心一点？是你还是她？
Her. Her. Yeah. Chaos I'm fine with. But man is like, rudeness, I don't tolerate. And that's when I... No, me neither. Yeah.
她。她。对。混乱我没问题。但人际方面，粗鲁无礼，我是容不下的。那就是我……不，我也是。对。
How old are yours now, Jason? I got 16 and 11. Two girls. Oh, wow. Yeah. It's totally permissive and the guy that plays around and I don't have to really be the disciplinarian. But if it's the rudeness, if it's stuff like that, and I just like the switch gets thrown. Yeah.
杰森，你的孩子现在多大了？我有16岁和11岁的。两个女孩。哦，哇。对。完全是放任型的，我是那个陪他们玩、不用真正扮演严厉管教者角色的人。但如果是粗鲁无礼，如果是诸如此类的事情，我内心的开关就会被触发。对。
Same. Same. I can choose my moments. Yeah. The chaos is great. Yeah. Yeah. We've got 14, 12, and then my partner is a five-year-old and then we have an almost three-year-old.
一样。一样。我可以选择发作的时机。对。混乱的感觉很棒。对。对。我们有14岁、12岁的，然后我的伴侣还有一个5岁的，然后我们还有一个快3岁的。
Oh, wow. All boys. All boys. No way. Yeah. You've almost got the hockey team. Almost got the team. And it's the fuck.
哦，哇。全都是男孩。全都是男孩。不会吧。对。你几乎可以组建一个冰球队了。快要凑够一支队伍了。简直是一团糟。
And it is... Sometimes it is absolute, just abject chaos. Like just... How do you like it? I love it. The chaos. It's great. Yeah.
而且这……有时候这绝对是，纯粹的混乱。就像……你觉得怎么样？我喜欢。这种混乱。太棒了。对。
I love it. It's... I don't know. I just wouldn't have it any other way. I embrace it. It's fun. Same thing. All...
我喜欢。这……我不知道。我绝不会希望它是别的样子。我拥抱它。这很有趣。一样的情况。所有……
They're all nice. They're all nice kids and everybody, you know, has good manners and stuff. That's one of the things. But I love it, man. I love it when it just gets absolute, you know, sometimes when you get into the witching hour, sort of near bedtime, it gets fucking bonkers. Yeah. How about the complications, Matthew, of traveling stuff, since you guys are both very active
他们都是好孩子。他们都是好孩子，每个人，你知道的，都有很好的礼貌什么的。这是其中之一。但我喜欢，老兄。我喜欢那种彻底爆发的时候，你知道的，有时当你进入“魔鬼时间”（指幼儿哭闹难缠的时段），接近睡觉时间时，简直他妈的要疯了。对。马修，旅行之类的事情有什么麻烦吗？既然你们俩在事业上都非常活跃，而且你们的孩子现在深度融入了学校生活，拥有那种社交和学术上的连续性，所以你不能真的像你希望的那样随时把他们抱起来带到各地去，我敢打赌，对吧？你们是怎么处理这一点的？容易还是艰难？这确实很难。我是说，我们尽量遵循一个荒谬的规则：我们之中一个人工作，另一个人不工作，这样，你知道的，孩子们可以留在学校，但这只是……
in your careers and your kids are now deeply entrenched in school and having that sort of social and academic continuity, like you can't really pick them up and take them places with you as much as you want, I'll bet, right? How do you guys manage that? Is it easy or tough? It is tough. I mean, we try and live by this ridiculous rule where one of us works, one of us doesn't and that, you know, the kids stay at school, but it's just...
这从来没起过作用，对吧？没有。因为，比如，如果有人接到一个超棒的邀约，你根本无法拒绝，但这轮到你带孩子，你知道的……
That never works out, right? No. Because, like, what if somebody gets a great, great call and it's, you just can't say no, but this is your turn and, you know... Yeah. Yeah, this is what happened last year and grandma came in and, you know, the kids ate sugar for six solid months. They...
对。对，去年就是这样，外婆赶来救场，你知道的，孩子们连续六个月都在吃糖。他们……
They loved it. I think that my sort of view on it always is, is that you have this idea of how you want it to go. So you say, like, one of us is going to work, one of us is not. Whatever that thing is, and you try to set those parameters and you try to get as close to it as you can and you have to be flexible and allow yourself to, you know, that there are going to be moments when it's just pure chaos. Yes.
他们太喜欢了。我觉得我对这件事的看法一直是，你对事情的发展方向有一个预期。所以你会说，比如，我们俩有一个人去工作，一个人不去。无论那是什么，你试着设定这些参数，尽量做到最好，然后你必须保持灵活，允许自己去接受，你知道的，会有那么一刻，一切都是纯粹的混乱。是的。
And the truth is, kids are so incredibly resilient, like they don't know any different, you know? Right. No. They don't know any of them or flight attendants. She was gone two weeks of every month. That was just normal to me, you know? Just had my mom half the time.
而事实是，孩子们有着惊人的适应能力，他们根本不知道有什么不同，你知道的？对。不。他们什么都不知道，或者空姐。她每个月有两周不在家。对我来说这很正常，你知道的？有一半时间都是我妈妈在带我。
Yeah. And that was just normal. Yeah. I had my dad. No, right. So... Matthew's going to love this story. No, no.
对。那也很正常。对。我爸爸在。没错，对吧。所以……马修一定会喜欢这个故事。不，不。
Yeah. Go. So it starts with a Chevy Pontiac, the engine turning on. Yeah. And it ends with a peel out. Yeah. Just a peel out. Yeah.
对。说吧。所以故事从一辆雪佛兰庞蒂克开始，发动机启动了。对。以一个急转漂移结束。对。就是一个急转漂移。对。
And a real... And a sort of a distant kind of... Fuck you! Fuck you! Oh, man! John, this isn't true. Is it? Yeah.
还有一声真正的……还有一种远处的……去你的！去你的！哦，天哪！约翰，这不是真的。对吧？对。
It's true. My dad left him. That's five. And he's left his mom to keep an eye on all of them. And I stress and I... His father has one eye. And I'd stress and I. Matthew, it's brilliantly tragic.
是真的。我爸爸抛弃了他们。那是五个。他留下了他妈妈来照看他们所有人。我压力很大，而且……他父亲只有一只眼。而且我压力很大，并且。马修，这真是绝妙的悲剧。
Tragic. You have to laugh. It's fine. Yeah. It's the only thing we have to do. We have to laugh at our misfortunes because... Yes. But wait, I'm going to ask you a weird question, only because you're wearing a black T-shirt.
悲剧。你只能笑。没关系。对。这是我们唯一能做的事。我们必须嘲笑我们的不幸，因为……是的。但是等等，我要问你一个奇怪的问题，只因为你穿着一件黑色T恤。
Yeah. And I've seen a lot of photos of you and stuff like where you seem very, you seem very kind of fat, like you're into fashion when you have to be. Like I know nothing, like I'm terrible. But like you're probably like Will, you're probably like Will where you're like, I like to look good when I even go to the store. I like to look good when I go out in public. Like is that, it seems like a lot of effort.
对。我看到过很多关于你的照片之类的，你看起来非常，你看起来非常那种，就像你很懂时尚，在需要的时候。就像我什么都不懂，就像我很糟糕。但你可能像威尔，你可能像威尔那样，你会觉得，我甚至去商店时也想看起来不错。我喜欢在公开场合露面时看起来不错。这是吗，这看起来需要付出很多努力。
Oh, no, no. If you truly knew me, it's, Kelly said the other day, because I have these beating up car hearts and I wear usually just the same black T-shirt every day. And even Kelly's like, you've got, you've got to change for the school run. You've worn the same thing for, it's now months. Right. And my car hearts are really beaten up and there's, there was this, there was this... What's cards?
哦，不，不。如果你真的了解我，凯莉前几天才说，因为我这些破旧的卡哈特（Carhartt）工装，而且我通常每天都穿同一件黑色T恤。甚至凯莉都说，你得，你得为了接送孩子上学换身衣服。你同一件衣服都穿了，现在已经好几个月了。对。而且我的卡哈特真的破烂不堪，然后有，然后有……什么是卡哈特？
Car hearts. Sorry, it's the way I'm saying it. It's a brand, clothing brand. Oh, car heart. It's like one of the carpenters, car heart here, all the carpenters wear them and they're real, real worker guys. And I wear them into the ground because it looks so terrible that there was, I was standing in school pickup in the line and this mother kind of looked at my travels and said, what,
卡哈特。抱歉，是我发音的问题。这是一个品牌，服装品牌。哦，卡哈特。就像那些木匠穿的，这里的卡哈特，所有的木匠都穿它们，它们是真正的，真正的工人的衣服。我把它们穿得稀巴烂，因为看起来太糟糕了，当时有，我当时站在学校接孩子的队伍里，这位母亲看了看我的行头，然后说，你，
what is it you do? And I went, I went, oh, I'm actually an actor and she went, oh, oh, it's like, I was like, why are you masquerading as someone who works for a living? Well, you have your uniform. Well, it's like Jason always gets the question when they see him. They always say, what, what, what, what time's your tea time? Right? Isn't that the question?
你是做什么的？然后我说了，我说了，哦，我其实是个演员，然后她说，哦，哦，就像是，我就想，你为什么要把自己伪装成一个靠出卖劳动力谋生的人？好吧，你有你的制服。好吧，这就像杰森每次见到他们时都会被问到的问题。他们总是问，你，你，你，你的下午茶时间是几点？对吧？难道不是这个问题吗？
You know what I wear at this little outfit, it's, it's clear, you know what I do get a lot, you know what I do get a lot is, do you, do you color your hair? And now recently, because of this, this film where I play in a guy in 1985, they think it's a wig, just a full blown wig that I'm wearing. Yeah. I'm looking forward to that immensely. No one thinks that my hair is the right, is the real color and it's just because in your seventies, like you are, it's not, it's unbelievable that a 70 year old would not
你知道我穿着这套小衣服，它，很明显，你知道我经常听到的是什么，你知道我经常听到的是，你，你染发吗？而最近，因为这部电影，我在里面扮演一个1985年的家伙，他们以为这是假发，完全是一顶假发，我戴着假发。对。我非常期待那个。没有人认为我的头发是正确的，是原本的颜色，这只是因为当你七十多岁时，就像你一样，它不是，一个七十岁的人竟然不
be here. I, I, I have to admit that there have been, I've had a few people in the last year who have asked me, Jason, if you color my hair. Yeah. Same. I tell everyone that you color your hair. It's just what it is. Yes.
在这里，这真是难以置信。我，我，我必须承认，在过去的的一家里，确实有几个人问过我，杰森，你是不是染发了。对。一样。我告诉每个人你染了头发。事情就是这样。是的。
Son of a bitch. It was, it was, yeah, it was during that, it was during that moment. Do you remember what, do you remember, I don't know if you remember this in the golden globes, that is, this is sound perversely pretentious, but it still makes me laugh, that kind of green, the virtual green room, if you remember, is you, me, Bob, Odin, Kirk, Josh, O'Connor, and then we were all waiting for Al Pacino to kind of pop up, do you remember, into the virtual green room and we're all waiting, we're all waiting and then he pops up because we're all at home during the pandemic and he looks like a Bond villain because he has
王八蛋。那是，那是，是的，是在那个时候，在那个时刻。你还记得，你还记得，我不知道你是否还记得金球奖上的那一幕，这听起来可能有点反常地自命不凡，但它仍然让我觉得好笑，那种绿色的，虚拟绿教室，如果你还记得的话，是你、我、鲍勃·奥登科克、乔什·奥康纳，然后我们都在等着阿尔·帕西诺出现，你还记得吗，进入虚拟绿教室，我们都在等，我们都在等，然后他出现了，因为我们在大流行期间都在家，他看起来像个邦德反派，因为他
like a small dog in his lap and he's choking it. Yeah. Yes. And we all sort of say, we all say, hi, hello. Hello. Hi, hi, hi. Hey, I'm in the middle of a Christmas violence and then we got into a second round and well I'm like going, hello hot, no nothing.
膝盖上有一只小狗，他在掐着它。对。是的。然后我们大家都说，我们大家都说，嗨，你好。你好。嗨，嗨，嗨。嘿，我正忙着过一个圣诞节呢。然后我们进入了第二轮，我一边说，你好，热，什么都没有。
And then I think you said, I don't think he can hear us. And then Pacino just goes, oh, I can hear you. Oh boy. We all went oh. Oh. Just doesn't wanna do the group hi. And then he said, I think he colors his head. Yeah.
然后我想你说，我觉得他听不见我们说话。然后帕西诺就说，哦，我能听见你们说话。哦，天哪。我们都“哦”了一声。哦。就是不想进行这种集体的“嗨”。然后他说，我想他染了头发。对。
Oh, this guy, oh, oh! Oh, hey, so, so Matthew. What's the problem, Charlie? Yeah. Good question for Jason. Why is the emblem, why is the person holding an umbrella? What is that? Oh, this is some silly golf sweater.
哦，这家伙，哦，哦！哦，嘿，所以，所以马修。有什么问题吗，查理？对。给杰森的一个好问题。为什么这个标志，为什么这个人拿着一把伞？那是什么？哦，这是一件傻乎乎的高尔夫毛衣。
Mary Poppins. Oh yeah, what is that? It actually is a Mary Poppins. This is a, I believe this is an ATT thing, Willie. Yeah. From ATT? Yeah, this is one of the... From that swag room we went into?
玛丽·波平斯。哦，对，那是什么？这其实是一件玛丽·波平斯。这件是，我相信这是一件ATT的东西，威利。对。来自ATT？对，这是其中一件……从我们进去的那个礼品室拿的？
Free sweater. We have smartless golf stuff coming out soon. I love it. Let's take the opportunity to do a merch tie-in shot. Smart. What's he saying? Matthew, Matthew, can you commit right now to wearing smartless golf merch on the school run?
免费毛衣。我们很快就会推出SmartLess的高尔夫周边产品。我喜欢。让我们借此机会拍一个周边产品的植入镜头。聪明。他在说什么？马修，马修，你现在能承诺在接送孩子上学时穿SmartLess的高尔夫周边吗？
My entire closet is mainly made up of clothes I've stolen from jobs. I don't buy a thing. Well, we're going to send you some smartless golf swag. I love it. So like some plus fours, right? For the golf events, you know, you can wear that. Yeah.
我的整个衣橱主要由我从工作中顺来的衣服组成。我什么都不买。好吧，我们要给你寄一些SmartLess的高尔夫周边。我喜欢。所以就像一些灯笼裤（plus fours），对吧？为了高尔夫活动，你知道的，你可以穿那个。对。
We were listening, I do want to say, your show gives us so much joy. And we were listening. Yes, it does. We were listening to it recently. And, Will, I think you went to dinner with Sean at Jar and Sean, you were... Yeah, I was not invited. Yeah.
我们一直在听，我确实想说，你们的节目给我们带来了极大的快乐。我们在听。是的，确实如此。我们最近一直在听。而且，威尔，我想你和肖恩去Jar餐厅吃过晚餐，肖恩，你……对，我没有被邀请。对。
Well, we brought that up in the car. We were like, I wasn't chasing. Yeah, I never am. These guys have been all over the world together. Oh my gosh. I've never asked. I mean, they've been to Turkey. They've been to, where else, guys? Yeah, we have.
好吧，我们在车里提起了这件事。我们当时想，我没有去，杰森。对，我从来没有。这些家伙一起去过世界各地。哦，天哪。我从来没问过。我的意思是，他们去过土耳其。他们去过，还有哪里，伙计们？对，我们去过。
Where has your passports been stamped? Venice Italy, right? Venice Italy? You guys play golf every day. OK, go ahead. It's different. So you did say that you were wearing Uggs. What are those kind of slipper Uggs for dinner?
你们的护照都在哪里盖过章？威尼斯，意大利，对吧？威尼斯，意大利？你们天天打高尔夫。好吧，继续。那不一样。所以你确实说过你穿着UGG。那是那种穿去吃晚餐的拖鞋式的UGG吗？
Is that right? Did I remember that right? Absolutely, yeah. And I said to Kevin, see, it's fine. And she went, they live in LA. Right. Sean, that was you wearing the comfy shoes? Yeah. Yeah, why not? He's been doing it for years.
是这样吗？我记错了吗？绝对的，是的。我对凯文说，看，没事的。然后她回答说，他们住在洛杉矶。对。肖恩，那是穿着舒服鞋子的你吗？对。对，为什么不呢？他这么做已经好几年了。
He's been doing it for years. Who looks at your shoes? Nobody looks at your shoes in a dark restaurant. I would. And then I would choose to never come to dinner with you again. Cobblers around the world. Cobblers. Listen, so Matthew, so now recently,
他这么做已经好几年了。谁会看你的鞋子？在昏暗的餐厅里没有人会看你的鞋子。我会的。然后我会选择再也不跟你一起去吃饭了。全世界的鞋匠。鞋匠。听着，所以马修，所以现在最近，
in the last couple of years, you've partnered with our good friend, Mr. Downey Jr. Oh, yeah, Perry Mason. Now, that's a handsome-looking show. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Talk to us a little bit about that. First of all, how that came about and what an absolute terror he is as an executive producer.
在过去的几年里，你和我们的好朋友小罗伯特·唐尼先生合作了。哦，对了，佩里·梅森。现在，那是一部看起来很帅气的剧。对，对，对，对，对，对。跟我们聊聊这个吧。首先，这是怎么促成的，以及作为一名执行制片人，他是一个多么彻头彻尾的恐怖分子。
Oh, this Downey. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. He's a shit. Yells and screaming. Oh, what a screamer. He strikes people. Yes, yes, with a glove.
哦，这个唐尼。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。他是个混蛋。大喊大叫。哦，真是个大喊大叫的人。他打人。是的，是的，用手套。
Has a leather glove, a small gauntlet that he sometimes put a metal thimble in it just for the little, ah! Yeah. Oh, Christ, he's here, he's here. He speaks so highly of you. How did that come? How did that?
有一只皮手套，一个小护手，有时他在里面放一个金属顶针，只是为了那种，啊！对。哦，天哪，他来了，他来了。他对你评价很高。这是怎么开始的？怎么会这样？
Yeah, he loves you. Yeah, he does, he really does. Robert loves you. And talk to us a little bit about it. And Susan as well. Susan does not like, oh, she does. Well, yes. The great Susan, the brains of that duo.
对，他爱你。是的，他确实，他真的很爱你。罗伯特爱你。跟我们稍微聊聊这个。还有苏珊。苏珊不喜欢，哦，她喜欢。好吧，是的。伟大的苏珊，那二人组的大脑。
If I may. The wind beneath the wings and the brain in the head. Yeah, how did that come into your sort of, into your world, the Perry Mason project? I mean, I'm trying to think what year it was now because it was a while back. Probably three, four years ago, maybe? Yes, yes, yes.
如果我可以这么说的话。翅膀下的风和头脑中的大脑。对，这个项目是怎么进入你的世界的，那个《佩里·梅森》项目？我是说，我在想现在是哪一年了，因为那已经是好久以前了。大概三、四年，也许吧？是的，是的，是的。
And I always, this is how my brain works. When my manager calls and he goes, you know, team down, he want to talk to you about a reboot of Perry Mason. My first question was like, who's turned it down? Who's turned it down? Right. Why does Robert want to do it? Yes, and I think he did.
我总是，我的大脑是这样运作的。当我的经纪人打电话来说，你知道的，唐尼团队想要跟你谈谈关于重启《佩里·梅森》的事。我的第一个问题是，谁拒绝了？谁拒绝了？对。为什么罗伯特想做这个？是的，我想是的。
I think that was the whole point that Robert was supposed to do it. And it took them almost 10 years of development. And it went through many, many, many guises of a TV film, a series, and I just think Robert never quite got there. So, yeah, they reached out for a meeting, which I was terrified about. And the brilliant Mr. Van Patten directed that?
我想这正是关键所在，本来应该是罗伯特自己演的。他们花了将近10年的时间来开发。它经历了很多很多很多种形式，电视电影、电视剧，而我只是觉得罗伯特一直没能完全推进下去。所以，是的，他们联系我开个会，我当时吓坏了。才华横溢的蒂姆·范·帕滕执导了那部剧吗？
Oh, my God. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was just a dream. By the way, I love that their company is called Team Downey, which is always fun to me. I think that's a great company name. I've always been jealous of that. But I don't want Robert to know.
哦，天哪。对，对，对。简直就像个梦。顺便说一句，我喜欢他们公司叫“唐尼团队”（Team Downey），这对我来说总是很有趣。我觉得那是一个很棒的公司名字。我一直对此很嫉妒。但我不想让罗伯特知道。
I would have called it Touch Downey. Yeah. Oh, that's good. That'd be good too, right? That's fun. Yeah, it's fun. It's just like I'm looking to rename mine, Master Bateman, but it has not cleared.
我本会把它命名为“触摸唐尼”（Touch Downey）。对。哦，那挺好。那也不错，对吧？挺有趣的。对，挺有趣的。就像我正考虑把我的公司重命名为“马斯特·贝特曼”（Master Bateman），但还没有通过审批。
So Robert, so Team Downey reaches out, and you go and you meet with these guys, and you're like, did you know that it was going to become this group? Like, what was your first thought of it? Were you excited? Were you sort of skeptical? Were you? I mean, I was slightly skeptical, because I have.
所以罗伯特，所以唐尼团队联系了你，然后你去和这些家伙见面，你会想，你知道它会变成这样一个团队吗？就像，你对它的第一想法是什么？你很兴奋吗？你有点怀疑吗？你当时是怎样的？我是说，我稍微有点怀疑，因为我有。
Like, did you develop it with them, or was it a script? Well, you're also carrying a bunch of pedigree out of the Americans, one, the Emmy. The Americans and brothers and sisters that you did for five years with our old buddy, Robbie Bates, my old friend. You did not want it to suck. No, no.
就像，你是和他们一起开发的，还是拿到剧本时就已经这样了？好吧，你身上也背着《美国谍梦》的光环，还有你和我们的老朋友罗比·贝茨（Robbie Bates）——我的老朋友——一起演了五年的《兄弟姐妹》。你可不想把它搞砸。不，不。
But that was never in doubt, because I think when you saw Team Downey, the writers on it, Tim Van Patten, HBO, it was kind of, it was straight of, I wasn't concerned that it wouldn't be of a certain caliber. If anything, it usually stems from my own insecurities, how I can turn it into a catastrophe more than anything else, but I was very excited. I loved it.
但那是毋庸置疑的，因为我想当你看到唐尼团队、编剧、蒂姆·范·帕滕、HBO时，它基本上，我并不担心它达不到某个特定的水准。如果有的话，这通常源于我自己的不安全感，比起其他任何事，我更担心自己怎么把它变成一场灾难，但我非常兴奋。我很喜欢。
It was pitched as a one-off, and they were like, look, we just want to do the origin story, and that'll be it. And then halfway through, they were like, you know, it works pretty good. It looks good. We should think about doing this, you know, we should think about doing more of this. I did have that small reservation where I've done,
当时它的推销是一次性的，他们说，看，我们只想拍前传故事，那就这样了。然后拍到一半的时候，他们说，你知道的，效果相当不错。看起来不错。我们应该考虑拍这个，你知道的，我们应该考虑拍更多这样的东西。我确实有那么一点小保留，因为我拍过，
where I kind of, you know, Perry Mason's sort of revered. Well, it was in the UK. It was huge. And here, also, there is a certain generation of an age group up that kind of go, no, no, no, you can't touch Mason. You know, after you have to leave that alone. And then a ton of people have no recollection of the show whatsoever.
我有点，你知道的，《佩里·梅森》这种剧备受尊崇。好吧，在英国是这样的。它太火了。而在美国，同样，有一代特定年龄层的人会说，不，不，不，你不能碰梅森。你知道的，你得放过它别动。然后有大量的人对这部剧完全没有任何记忆。
And that's what Susan said. She said, look, there's an entire, there are swathes of generations ready for a new Perry Mason. Yeah, we can do it. We can make it whatever we want. And where did you guys shoot that? In LA. They went back to the origin story in the books,
而这正是苏珊所说的。她说，看，有整整一代人，有大批的世代已经准备好迎接一个新的《佩里·梅森》了。是的，我们可以做到。我们可以把它拍成我们想要的任何样子。你们是在哪里拍摄的？在洛杉矶。他们回到了书中的前传故事，
which was 1930s LA, which to me was, you know, with Chinatown and everything else was such, was so alluring. And as a kid growing up watching old movies, I was like, oh my god, I get to wear a fedora in LA. And you do an American accent? Yeah, yeah. You get to wear a fedora in LA like everybody else in Venice,
也就是20世纪30年代的洛杉矶，对我和唐人街以及其他一切来说，那是如此的诱惑。作为一个从小看老电影长大的孩子，我当时想，哦，天哪，我能在洛杉矶戴上一顶软呢帽了。而且你要说美国口音？对，对。你可以在洛杉矶戴上一顶软呢帽，就像威尼斯的其他人一样，
right? In LA or Los Feliz, yeah. As an actor, is the American accent a tough thing to do? And do you have like a phrase that clicks you right into the typical American sound that's sort of like a shortcut for you? No, there's no real shot. It's still, it's still a huge, it's like a, I say block.
对吧？在洛杉矶或者洛斯费利兹（Los Feliz），是的。作为一名演员，美国口音是一件很难掌握的事情吗？你有没有那种能让你立刻切入典型美国发音的短语，就像是你的捷径一样？不，没有什么真正的捷径。它仍然，它仍然是一个巨大的，就像一个，我说“block”（街区）。
Like hamburger. Well, I tell you what, oh yeah, I tell you what, killer. I went up to one of the writers early on in Perry Mason. And I said, hey, is there any chance we can change like murderer to killer? And he's like, you do realize you've signed on for Perry Mason. Like you're going to be saying murderer a lot. And I was like, yeah, I hadn't quite thought that one too.
像“hamburger”（汉堡）。好吧，我告诉你，哦，对，我告诉你，杀人犯（killer）。我在《佩里·梅森》早期曾去找过其中一位编剧。我说，嘿，我们有没有可能把比如“murderer”（凶手）改成“killer”（杀人犯）？他说，你得意识到你签约的是《佩里·梅森》。你得经常说“murderer”这个词。我说，对，我之前没太考虑到这一点。
That's a bit of an Achilles heel for me. That's why I always sound like I'm right. That's a tough word to say. Yeah, like your batteries run out halfway through, you just go murderer. Murder, murderer. I was like, can you say killer? What about suspect?
对我来说这有点像是阿喀琉斯之踵。这就是为什么我听起来总是像我说的对。这是一个很难发音的词。对，就像你的电池用到一半没电了，你只能说“murderer”（凶手）。凶手，凶手。我当时想，你能说“killer”吗？“suspect”（嫌疑人）呢？
Suspect would be great. Right, because the British accent would put an A-H on it, murderer. Murderer, murderer, murderer. Murderer, murderer. By the way, if you're going to live in America, you got to learn how to say murderer. I mean, sorry.
“Suspect”会很棒。对，因为英国口音会在上面加一个“哈”音，比如 murderer。Murderer, murderer, murderer. Murderer, murderer. 顺便说一句，如果你要在美国生活，你得学会怎么说 murderer。我是说，抱歉。
Yeah, I know. She's so true. You're going to say the most. Jesus Christ. Well, so now you've got the second season of Perry Mason coming out, which is fantastic. Would you never thought you'd do? No.
是的，我知道。她说得太对了。你得说得最多。天哪。好吧，所以现在你的《佩里·梅森》第二季要播出了，这太棒了。你以前从没想过你会拍第二季吧？没有。
And that was delayed a bit, yeah? With COVID, perhaps? Hugely delayed, because it's too soon to, you know, definitely, no, we're going to wait. We're not going to shrink the show and make a smaller show of the first one. We'll wait until we can make the same big show with hundreds of supporting artists and do it right.
而且那推迟了一段时间，对吧？可能是因为新冠疫情？极大地推迟了，因为太早了，你知道的，当然不行，我们要等。我们不会把剧缩水，拍得比第一季小。我们要等到能拍出同样规模宏大、有几百名群演的大制作，并且把它做好。
Right, because there's a lot of background players in a lot of crowd scenes, yeah. It's a massive production. Oh, it might. It's a beast. There are those days I turn up on set and I go, I don't even know how this works. My brother-in-law was a tank commander in the British Army.
对，因为有很多背景演员和很多群演场景，是的。这是一部庞大的制作。哦，可能会是。这是个庞然大物。有些日子我出现在片场，然后我想，我甚至不知道这怎么运作。我的连襟是英国陆军的坦克车长。
Whoa. For most of his life. And he said it's all, it's like, if you think about the logistics, they have to do, it's insane. But he came on set one day and he went, how does this work? Right, yeah.
哇。他大半生都是。他说这一切，就像，如果你去想他们必须进行的后勤工作，那是疯狂的。但他有一天来到片场，然后说，这到底是怎么运作的？对，是的。
And he was just so shocked. He goes, what amazes me, he said, what amazes me is that so many components have to come together in one tiny moment and be quiet. He said it was, it sort of staggered him. And he was like, he was like, amazed at the cool sheets and everything. It is.
他当时太震惊了。他说，让我惊讶的是，他说，让我惊讶的是，这么多组件必须在同一个微小的时刻组合在一起，并且保持安静。他说这，这有点震惊到他了。他说他，他对外景的井井有条之类的东西感到震惊。确实如此。
It's true. When you watch, when you go to a, when you go to a big film television set and you watch all these people who are at the top of their game and they're seeing, like you said, coming together in that moment where everything's got to be silent and everything's got to be great and you see it pulled off. Sometimes it has the timing of something
真的。当你观看，当你去一个，当你去一个大型电影电视片场，看着所有这些处于他们领域巅峰的人，他们正在目睹，就像你说的，在那个时刻汇聚在一起，所有事情都必须保持安静，所有事情都必须完美，然后你看着它成功完成。有时它有那种，
that has to happen in the shot. Whatever it is, it is pretty amazing to watch how good these people are at what they do. Yeah. And filming, filming in New York, which we obviously did the Americans on, it's staggering that they get away with what they do in the kind of, like location department
必须在镜头中发生的事情的时间控制。无论如何，看着这些人把他们擅长的事做得这么好，真的是太神奇了。对。而且在纽约拍电影，我们显然在纽约拍过《美国谍梦》，他们能靠外景部门在那种地方全身而退，这简直让人震惊，
should be given flak jackets these days for the amount of abuse they just get from people who want to park, drive down the street or, you know, enter a shop. But how many times have you had that when you're shooting in New York on the street and then some, it's like pretty good. And then like somewhere in the tech,
如今他们应该发防弹背心了，因为他们经常受到那些想停车、想开车穿过街道或者想进商店的人的各种谩骂。但当你在纽约街头拍戏时，有多少次你会遇到这种情况，然后某个，这感觉挺好的。然后就像在科技中，
you just hear somebody out, leaning out a window going, I want to be in the fucking movie. All the time. All right, let's go again. If it says exterior night in the Americans, you know you're looping it. You know you're ADRing it
你会听到某个人探出窗外大喊，我想演这部该死的电影！一直都是这样。好吧，我们重来。如果剧本上写着外景夜晚《美国谍梦》，你就知道你得后期配音了。你知道你得做对白替换（ADR），
because you know there's someone shouting along the line. There was this one time in Harlem I was doing a scene and it was like eight guys, because I had to shout the scene, eight guys were shouting the exact same words along with me and the director said. Because they've heard it so many times. Yeah, yeah.
因为你知道会有人在旁边大喊大叫。有一次在哈莱姆区，我正在拍一场戏，大概有八个人，因为我必须在戏里大喊大叫，有八个人跟着我一起大喊着完全相同的台词，导演说。因为他们听了太多遍了。对，对。
Matthew, we have taken up so much of your time. My God, I just realized we could talk to you. This has been a treat. This has been a treat. Ever. Yeah, yeah. In a real treat. You're one of us.
马修，我们占用了你太多的时间。天哪，我刚刚意识到我们可以跟你聊天。这真是一种享受。这真是一种享受。从来没有。对，对。真的是一种享受。你就是我们的一员。
You're one of us. You're one of us. God, I'm one of us. This has been a real treat. Sean, I can't wait to see the show. We're all coming to see it. We're very excited about it. Oh, that's so nice.
你就是我们的一员。你就是我们的一员。天哪，我成了你们的一员。这真是一次真正的享受。肖恩，我迫不及待想看这部剧了。我们都要去看。我们对此非常兴奋。哦，太好了。
Thank you. How are previews going? Really well, really exhausting, but thank you for asking. I walked down the street one day today, walked down the street to go get my little sandwich, my egg sandwich. Anna Kaiser roll.
谢谢。预演进展得怎么样？非常好，非常累，但谢谢你问起。我今天走在街上，走在街上去买我的小三明治，我的鸡蛋三明治。一个凯撒卷。
Anna Kaiser roll. And this woman stopped me. She was really sweet, but this is how much energy was in her voice. She grabbed my arm and she goes, I saw your show last night. I go, yeah. Thank you for coming.
一个凯撒卷。然后这个女人拦住了我。她人真的很好，但她说话时的能量太足了。她抓住我的胳膊说，我昨晚看了你的演出。我说，对。谢谢你能来。
She goes, this is really good. And she's just fucking. I love New York. Oh. New York undefeated. And that's it. I was like, yeah. She was very nice though.
她说，这真的很好。然后她就他妈的。我太喜欢纽约了。哦。纽约保持不败。就是这样。我当时想，对。不过她人非常好。
Last time I did a play, I was walking from the theater and this woman just shouted, you're an asshole. And I just went, I hope you saw the show. That's not personal. Uh-huh. Matthew, well, when we come to New York,
上次我演话剧时，我正从剧院走出来，有个女人大喊，你是个混蛋！我当时就回了句，我希望你看了那场演出。这不是针对个人的。嗯哼。马修，好吧，当我们去纽约时，
I hope that we can grab a meal. You, me, Carrie, and maybe one of these ding-dongs as well. That would be a ding-dong. Let's go. Yes, please. Get Sean and Scotty and JB and we'll do it up. It'll be great to see you, man.
我希望我们能一起吃顿饭。你、我、凯莉，可能还有这些傻瓜里的一个。那真是一个傻瓜。我们走吧。好，请吧。叫上肖恩、斯科蒂和JB，我们大干一场。能见到你太棒了，老兄。
Thank you for having me. This has been such a treat. Thank you, Matthew. And send all of our love to Carrie. I will. We adore her as well. And we adore you. You are, as Sean said,
谢谢你们邀请我。这真是一大享受。谢谢你，马修。并代我们向凯莉问好。我会的。我们也崇拜她。我们也崇拜你。正如肖恩所说，
you're one of us. It's been such a pleasure, buddy. And a continued success. Perry Mason comes out. What's the release? It's... It's out now. It's out now.
你就是我们的一员。非常荣幸，老兄。祝你百尺竿头更进一步。《佩里·梅森》要上映了。什么时候上映？是……现在已经上映了。现在已经上映了。
Monday nights at nine. Yeah. Monday nights at nine. There we go. HBO Max, yeah. HBO. Congratulations, Matthew. Yeah, congratulations.
每周一晚九点。对。每周一晚九点。就这样。HBO Max，对。HBO。恭喜你，马修。对，恭喜。
All the success, buddy. Thank you, guys. Thanks a million. Thanks for being here, buddy. Have a good day. See you soon. Bye-bye. And you slam it shut.
祝你一切顺利，老兄。谢谢你们，伙计们。非常感谢。谢谢你能来，老兄。祝你今天过得愉快。回头见。再见。然后你把它“啪”地关上了。
Now, there's a nice guy. Well, what's a nice guy like that being... How is he friends with you? Because that's the kind of... That's the ilk of people that I attract. You know what I mean? It's just like-minded people. Birds of a feather, cool dudes.
看，真是个好人。好吧，像这样一个好人怎么会……他怎么会跟你做朋友？因为这就是我吸引的那类人。你知道我的意思吗？就是志同道合的人。物以类聚，都是酷咖。
Charming. He knows how to carry on a conversation. Yeah, I know. I'm always impressed with guys like that who are just so, like, relaxed. Yeah. Like... Well, he's confident.
迷人。他知道怎么把对话进行下去。对，我知道。对于那些总是那么……放松的家伙，我总是印象深刻。对。就像……好吧，他很自信。
You know? He's comfortable. You know, he's got his uniforms. He has his black t-shirt and his... He's not like you guys. He doesn't have an axe to grind. You know what I mean? He doesn't have something to prove all the time.
你知道吗？他很自在。你知道的，他有他的制服。他有他的黑色T恤和他的……他可不像你们这些人。他没有要宣泄的不满。你知道我的意思吗？他不用时时刻刻证明什么。
He's not trying to prove anything with his fun tops that he wears, Sean. I'm a fun top. Now, listen. I know you are. Speaking of which, where's the cocaine bear? What's he fixing now? Huh?
他不是在试图通过他穿的那些花哨上衣来证明什么，肖恩。我穿的才是花哨上衣。现在，听着。我知道你是。说到这个，那个“可卡因熊”呢？他现在在弄什么？啊？
He's fixing something. Scotty, what are you making? What kind of sandwich? What kind of sandwich? Oh, you had a turks. You had a turk sandwich. Oh, a turk sandwich? What else is on it?
他在弄点什么。斯科蒂，你在做什么？什么三明治？什么三明治？哦，你吃了一个火鸡肉三明治。哦，火鸡肉三明治？里面还有什么？
What percentage of the day? What percentage of the day? Hang on. What percentage of the day when you yell out, hey, Scotty, what are you doing? Raise the answer. I'm making a sandwich. Well, usually it's for me.
一天里有多大比例？一天里有多大比例？等等。一天里，当你大喊“嘿，斯科蒂，你在干嘛？”时，回答的比例是多少？我在做三明治。好吧，通常是给我做的。
No, that's what I mean. Making sammies. That's what I mean. Well, so what do we got on the turkey? So how do you like your turkey sandwich done, Sean? I ordered one yesterday for lunch. It was a turkey, avocado, lettuce, and extra, extra, extra mayo. And are we toasting the bread?
不，我是那个意思。做三明治。我是那个意思。好吧，那我们的火鸡肉三明治里都有什么？肖恩，你喜欢怎么做火鸡肉三明治？我昨天午餐点了一个。里面有火鸡肉、牛油果、生菜，还有超级、超级、超级多的蛋黄酱。我们把面包烤一下吗？
No. Really? How about a light toast with a little snap on it? Just like a real soft thing there. Extra. Do you literally say extra, extra, extra mayo? Yes, I always do, because they never put enough oil. You know what I like?
不。真的吗？稍微烤一下，带点脆感怎么样？就像里面那种非常软的东西。超多。你真的会说“超级、超级、超级多的蛋黄酱”吗？对，我一直都这么说，因为他们从来不放足够的油。你知道我喜欢什么吗？
I like it when you get one of those, like, sort of like an Italian, you know what I mean? With different cuts of meat, some cold cuts, lettuce, tomato, and get some oil and vinegar, get a little salt peps. Stuff it in there. Stuff it in there. By the way, it reminds me of what I was saying,
我喜欢那种，比如，有点像意大利风格的，你知道我的意思吗？里面有不同的肉片、一些冷盘肉、生菜、西红柿，再加点油和醋，撒点盐和胡椒。把它塞满。把它塞满。顺便说一句，这让我想起了我刚才说的，
about the wearing the hats all around. I remember Thoreau went through a long phase. He was always wearing like hats and little pork pie hats and fedoras and stuff. And I remember Polar, Polar said to him one day, you look fedorable and it just really killed us. Hey, what kind of hat do I have on today? You got one of those smartless merch hats.
关于到处戴帽子的事。我记得梭罗（Thoreau）经历过很长一段时间。他总是戴着各种帽子、小圆帽、软呢帽之类的。我记得波拉（Polar）有一天对他说，你看起来太“呢”了（fedorable），这简直把我们笑死了。嘿，我今天戴的是什么帽子？你戴着一顶SmartLess周边帽。
That's right. Yeah. Wait, where do we get one of those? I started to interrupt, guys. It looks like Carrie Russell's entering the waiting room. She might just want to say hi. You want to just pop it. Put her on.
没错。对。等等，我们在哪能买到一顶？抱歉打断你们，伙计们。看起来凯莉·拉塞尔（Carrie Russell）正在进入候诊室。她可能只是想打个招呼。你想让她露个面吗？让她进来。
Put her on. Put Carrie on. Then we're going to air it. There she is. There she is. If you can hear us hello. We'll have to have her on. I will tell the boys they can't hear you right now
让凯莉进来。然后我们再播。她来了。她来了。如果你能听见我们说话，你好。我们得请她上节目。我得告诉小伙子们他们现在听不见你们说话，
because they're on the other system. You were fantastic. Thank you. Bye. Okay. Thanks for everything. Really appreciate it. Well done.
因为他们在另一个系统上。你太棒了。谢谢。再见。好的。谢谢你所做的一切。非常感激。干得好。
I love that we just had a quick visual visit from Carrie Russell. And we couldn't hear her, but we got to see her. And she was there. She was probably with the kids, right, Sean? Yes, she was probably with us. She probably would. It's about time for pickup. Yeah, it's probably for nap time for our kids,
我喜欢我们刚刚对凯莉·拉塞尔进行了短暂的视频访问。虽然我们听不见她的声音，但我们看到了她。她就在那儿。她可能跟孩子们在一起，对吧，肖恩？是的，她可能和我们在一起。她很可能。差不多是接孩子放学的时间了。对，可能到了我们孩子午睡的时间了，
which she would then sing. What would she sing to them? Oh my God. I'm going to put her kids to bed. She would probably sing like rock, rock, rock. Bye, baby, baby, baby. Jason hates when we go up. He just, he just pinches that voice off.
然后她就会唱歌。她会给他们唱什么？哦，天哪。我要把她的孩子哄睡着。她可能会唱像“rock, rock, rock”之类的。再见，宝贝，宝贝，宝贝。杰森最讨厌我们发出这种声音了。他总是，他总是掐断那种嗓音。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart, Lost, Smart, Lost. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbago. Smart, Lost.
再见。再见。再见。再见。SmartLess，SmartLess。SmartLess由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗伯·阿尔杰夫和贝内特·巴尔巴戈100%有机且手工制作。SmartLess。
Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Smart, Lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，也可以通过在Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用上订阅Wondery Plus来提前收听并免除广告。SmartLess。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。